everyone welcome to this Friday live
discussion as part of your daily
equation that you had a chance to join
me here for our little conversation
those of you who have been here in
previous Friday's knows that sometimes
little is very much in the eye of the
beholder it is absolutely not absolute
it is certainly one of the words of
relativity I don't know how long we'll
go today but you know if the past is any
guide we may be sitting here for a while
which can be fun I've certainly enjoyed
the discussions that we have had and let
me just quickly also note that I think
as I mentioned last time as I head into
next week I began to teach back at
Columbia I'll be teaching a course there
in the summer so it's going to be more
difficult for me together with a bunch
of other things that we're doing some of
you have also asked about World Science
Festival the regular programming that we
do we're gonna start rolling those
programs out over the next few weeks so
there's obviously a lot of effort and
time that goes into putting those
together so your daily equation the word
daily may also be relative I will
continue to do some of the episodes but
I won't be able to do them at the same
frequency I don't think as I've been
doing them before but you know we'll
play it play it by ear so just if you
have a little patience with me
flexibility with the the rate at which
we create them that that would be great
alright so let's let's get into the
discussion here and I realize that I've
got the wrong chat window open so let me
just fix that so I actually see yeah I
think this is the right one Justin
attends it says sup chat I think that
means that I'm on the right page if I'm
not thinking about things wrong good
okay so there was one question that
caught my eye yeah there it is
Andrew Hanny asks is it right to say
that reality is not absolute since
what's real differs with
different perspectives and that's um
that is a subtle that is a subtle
question what I would say is there are
certain qualities of the world that are
absolute in the sense that a very
specific sense that anybody who is
following a particular procedure to
measure or observe or quantify certain
aspects of the world around us will get
the same result for instance if you're
talking about the electric charge on the
electron or the mass of an electron
anybody who is using the appropriate
equipment in the right manner regardless
of where they are say on planet earth or
as far as we can tell
regardless of where they are you know
throughout at least the observable
universe we believe that they will get
the same value for the electric charge
of an electron or the mass of an
electron so those qualities of reality
do seem to be absolute in the sense that
everybody agrees on them in Einstein's
relativity there are other qualities of
the world that we believe to be absolute
to in fact you may be surprised to hear
and I'd be interested to know if you're
surprised here I mean look those of you
who've read popular physics books or
know the subject well know exactly what
I'm about to say but for those of you
for whom this material is new Einstein
didn't want to call relativity theory
relativity he wanted to call it
invariance theory invariant the things
that don't change you see because the
right way of thinking about say the
special theory of relativity is not that
Einstein made everything relative like
you hear people say that kind of
silliness a lot and if it's
tongue-in-cheek or if it's just meant in
a colloquial sense fine I mean use
language however you want in everyday
life but when you're talking about the
precise description of Einstein's
special theory of relativity it's not
that everything is relative what
Einstein showed is there are qualities
of the world that in the past we thought
were absolute and those qualities of the
world turn out to be relatives
space and time being the great examples
but he also showed that there are other
qualities of the world that are absolute
they're just not the qualities that
previous generations thought to be
absolute for instance if you have two
events that take place in the universe a
firecracker goes off over here and then
another firecracker goes off over there
you can think about the distance between
them in space how far apart the events
took place you can also think about the
distance between them in time the time
difference between them from your
perspective or anyone's perspective
different observers will disagree on the
spatial separation between those events
and the temporal separation between
those events however and here's the
beautiful thing
I'm Stein shows that there's another
quality another quantity depending upon
space and time that everybody will agree
on and in units where the speed of light
is equal to 1 that quantity is delta T
squared the time difference according to
any observer squared minus Delta x
squared the spatial separation squared
according to any observer so that
particular combination of space and time
is something that everybody will agree
on regardless of how they're moving
regardless of the configuration in which
they find themselves relative to the
events that they are witnessing so so
there you have it there is an absolute
quality of the world it's just not the
qualities that we thought to be real so
I would say in answer to the question
that there are absolute qualities of the
world reality is something that's out
there there are many features of reality
that are in the eye of the beholder both
metaphorically poetically and
scientifically but there are other
qualities of reality that everyone will
agree on I think they have every right
to be called the absolute qualities of
reality ok so that was a long answer to
our first question so anybody who's
still with me after that one let's see
what else we can get to here all right
from Kuwait great to see you guys from
friend Vancouver Canada and scroll in
Pakistan California yeah do do tell us
where y'all are coming from and in the
chat here oh here's one here's one and
many people have been asking me this
question so I think I should dispense
with it right now there was a report
that you may have seen that NASA has
found evidence of a parallel universe
where time goes backwards anybody see
that particular news report and so a lot
of people have asked me well well okay
is that is that really true what is that
what does that really mean
and and here's the situation so there
were some observations that have been
made of certain cosmic ray particles
what are cosmic rays you know the Sun
emits particles that travel through
space to hit our atmosphere they cause
various kind of interactions to take
place and showers of particles rain down
from the the sequence of processes that
I just just described and some of the
folks who were investigating these down
I guess it must be at the South Pole a
particular experiment called Anita they
found a strange result they found a
result is actually I think way back in
2016 so it's not a new result it's just
people are really thinking about it and
trying to understand it and they found
what seemed to look like the shower is
going up as opposed to down and and that
was quite confusing and it's hard to
make sense of that and many people have
put forward ideas for instance maybe
some of these particles that they are
observing somehow we're produced by the
ice and they're going that direction as
opposed to coming at us from space and
so forth so so the bottom line is many
people have tried to come up with
explanations for the data and my
understanding I've not actually gone
through the papers myself
my understanding is that none of those
explanations really are yet convincing
so it's an anomalous observation which
is not all that infrequent in science
it's one that's been around for a
handful of years and when you have
difficulty explaining an anomalous
observation after a couple of years some
of the more far-out explanations begin
to bubble up to the surface and one of
the farthest out explanations is that we
are witnessing particles in a parallel
universe that relative to our
orientation of time are travelling
backward in time and therefore they're
going in the wrong direction
explaining the weird observations so so
do I consider that to be evidence for a
parallel universe number one I don't I
consider it that's an interesting
explanation I'm glad it's on the table
I'm glad people kick it around but it's
gonna take a lot more than that to
convince me and I'm open to these ideas
I wrote a whole book on parallel
universes the hidden reality is all
about different flavors of parallel
universes you have to be very careful
when you claim that you've got evidence
for something so so radically distinct
from established science and it's going
to take a mountain of observational
experimental data to really convince us
of the possibility that these parallel
universes are real or that this
particular explanation is the one that
we should take seriously bottom line is
you know Carl Sagan perhaps said it best
I don't remember the exact wording but
something like extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence it's a
great quote right the notion of a
parallel universe or time runs backward
is an extraordinary claim it will
require extraordinary evidence and we do
not have that extraordinary evidence in
hand now
sociologically culturally the second
certain publications here of the
possibility that scientists may at least
be considering the possibility of
parallel universes with particles
traveling backward in time they kind of
tend to forget about all of the caveats
and all the other explanations that
people are kicking around and focus only
on that and then the word spreads
outward so I don't like to throw cold
water on excitement but I do have a
certain resistance and a certain
allergic reaction to the hyperbole and
the over-the-top headlines and the grand
excitement about some far-out sounding
idea because then when it's not true
people roll their eyes later on when
there is some extraordinary claim and it
is something that people really are
taking seriously and I would say that
the vast majority of physicists are not
at the moment coming to the conclusion
that the headline that I certainly read
in one of these articles that NASA finds
evidence of a parallel universe where
timing runs backward you ask most
physicists in the world today and they
will not say that that summarizes their
perspective
all right so Dom Cass Moreau said that
was too long an answer all right Dom I
will try to speak faster or use less
words going forward thank you for your
constructive criticism but right below
you someone said love you professor so
maybe there multiple perspectives on on
how much information I should give you
but whatever whatever you want to ask
I'll do my best answer it as concisely
as possible all right so what else do we
have here I've got to take my finger off
the scroll all right Maximilian agar
says what would be evidence for such a
claim then that's it that's a very good
question and well first of all you want
to make certain that the data is real so
you want to make certain that this is
not some one-off perhaps anomalous
experimental error right you may recall
that there was claimed some years ago
that particles were traveling faster
than the speed of light and it was an
experiment where particles neutrinos are
being shot through rock from one
location in gran sasso Italy I think
it's from CERN to Gran Sasso Italy and
the particles were arriving too soon
right and and so there were these claims
of faster than the speed of light the
speed of light limit has
been broken that speed limit has been
broken and most of us who said to
ourselves no I don't trust that
relativity it's been around so long
anything that violates it it's got to
take a mountain of experimental evidence
to support it and when the experiment
have went back and checked the equipment
very carefully you found that there was
a problem with equipment and when they
fix the problem the equipment the the
data went away so that's number one you
want to make sure that this is
replicable experimental data that you
see at a sufficient frequency that you
can really gain some statistical
confidence that this is not just some
weird anomaly with either the equipment
or some kind of other fluke in the
environment and when you rule out every
single possibility of a sort that is
closer to our perspective on the world
then parallel universes were time run
backward then then you then you get to a
place where you start to take it
seriously
we're not run out there yet all right so
let's see hmm there's one question I
think I understand but maybe it's an
internal conversation so I'm going to
let that one go let's see garden ask
isn't it crazy how time breaks down at
the beginning of the universe is it
because time and space work together and
well partly that is the answer again the
lesson that we learned from Einstein is
that the Newtonian perspective that
space is one thing and time is another
that is a perspective that needs to be
jettisoned and we learn that space and
time more or less as you described guard
and they're kind of woven together
that's why we use the language the
fabric of space-time as if they're woven
together in a particular pattern
dictated by the equations of relativity
and when you go back in time with your
mathematics not for real but use your
equations to turn the cosmic film ever
further back in time what you find in
our understanding of the universe is
that the density of matter and energy
gets higher
and higher and when the density as you
head back toward the beginning soars
toward the number infinity as basically
what the math tells you you realize that
it's not just that sort of time is
breaking down it's at our whole
mathematical architecture for
understanding what happens in the
earliest moment of the universe that is
breaking down you know sometimes I think
I said it before people have a sense
that the word singularity is some
mysterious concept some beautiful
mysterious Engel arity is coming the
singularity is near right and depending
what you mean by that
it can have a real meaning I'm not
trying to denigrate some of the folks
who speak that way but the bottom line
is in physics when we talk about
singularity it is a euphemism it is a
metaphor it is a word that actually
tells us that we don't know what is
going on
singularity means math breaks down we
don't know what's going on so it's not
that we can really say that time stops
at the Big Bang we can't say that time
begins at the Big Bang these are all
real possibilities but what we can say
is we don't have the math to give us
insight into what happens at time zero
and until we have equations that do not
break down under any circumstances
however extreme the environment may be
however dense the energy might be then
we are at a loss so we need those
equations that will never break down
under any circumstance we hope to one
day have them but I would say at the
moment we are lacking that kind of
technical understanding and that's what
prevents us from saying what happened at
time zero itself little bit von
Beethoven a regular on this discussion
professor me and some others have now a
subreddit called your daily equation
with an R a reddit slash your daily
questions discussed topics discussed
here or to ask for additional questions
do you approve of this initiative yeah
sure why not
I love conversations about the things
that we are focusing on and and look
like I might also mention to ever is
interested sorry I just took a shower
and they got war
in my ear I'm going to be doing a
semi-regular reddit discussion
conversation QA you may know that reddit
has this thing called our pan reddit
public access network I did it a couple
weeks ago is kind of fun a lot of people
were discussing the kinds of things that
we discuss here so I think that's going
to be Friday's from two to three maybe
every other week so I don't know how
long we'll continue our live sessions
but for at least a while you can join me
a two o'clock on that reddit access
network I'm sure you guys can find it I
don't even know where you gonna find it
and but yes of course anything that you
guys want to do to continue the
conversation that's that's that's
fantastic alright
Gayatri Pandit asked professor why does
string P require ten or eleven
dimensions and does having different
dimensions mean different universes or
shapes of objects and I wish I could
give you an answer for why string theory
requires 10 or 11 dimensions in the
sense of why 10 or 11 I think it may
have mentioned before I've never been
able to come up with anything but the
mathematical explanation of that so let
me just frame it this way there is an
equation in string theory which
to be satisfied for the theory to be
mathematically coherent if this
particular equation is not satisfied you
can prove that all sorts of weird things
would happen which would destroy the
viability of the theory you lose energy
conservation you lose all of the
essential details that make a
mathematical theory of the universe
viable worthy of attention in this
equation in some sense it counts the
number of vibrations of a given energy
of a vibrating string if a string is
vibrating say in just the plane in your
mind you can picture there are just so
many distinct vibrational patterns that
it can have if you go to a third
dimension now there are more distinct
vibrational patterns of a given energy
because not only can it vibrate this way
the string can also vibrate this way and
it's harder to picture but if you go to
four dimensions of space there yet more
vibrational patterns that are accessible
five dimensions more six dimensions more
and so forth so here's the thing when
you calculate the number of vibrational
punters necessary to solve that equation
that I mentioned a moment ago there
aren't enough vibrational patterns in
two dimensions of space and three at
four five and six and so on only when
you get to nine dimensions of space and
one dimension of time are there enough
vibrational patterns to satisfy that
equation I cannot convince you of the
number nine spatial dimensions but I
hope it gives you the flavor of
reasoning that connects the number of
dimensions of space with the viability
of the theory it's not that someone
sitting there and say wouldn't it be fun
to have extra dimensions of space people
did follow that approach way back in the
early part of the 20th century Colusa
klein they weren't being as facetious as
that of course but they were examining
the possibility of extra dimensions just
because it was an interesting
possibility and they were curious to see
whether physical law could make sense in
a world with extra dimensions and I
found some very interesting results
that's not what happens in string theory
in string theory
you do not posit the extra dimensions in
string theory you study the fundamental
mathematical equation of a vibrating
string in an existing space-time arena
and you find that that space-time arena
must have more than three spatial
dimensions for the fundamental equations
to be internally consistent that's a
completely different way of getting to
this idea of extra dimensions of space
and that's why it's much more convincing
finally to end this answer to this
question when you go to M theory this
more refined version of string theory
you learn that the approximations that
we had been making in conventional
string theory left out one spatial
dimension they were insensitive to one
spatial dimension and therefore nine
dimensions of space went up to ten
dimensions of space with time takes us
to eleven space-time dimensions so
that's the chain of reasoning and you
know some of you have asked me in one of
these episodes to explain this curious
fact you know that one plus two plus
three plus four plus five what does that
add up to someone just tell me in the
chat I'm sure some of you guys know what
that adds up to and infinity is one
answer and it's a fine answer but that's
not the answer that I'm looking at I'm
looking at a finite answer for adding up
all of the numbers and I think there's a
let me just see if I can see if anyone
has that answer for me well I'm waiting
I'm waiting maybe it will come in I
think there's a bit of a tight time
delay between when I there it is thank
you
walking Android minus 1/12 thank you
walking Android and and so people wanted
me to explain how it could be the real
flew non minus a12 how could be the one
plus two plus three could add up to
minus 1/12 and at some point I will do
that but that minus 1/12 it turns out is
one of the key ways of understanding how
it is that string theory requires the
extra dimensions that it does now a lot
of people now I guess that's the bit of
time delay between what I say and when
you hear it so I see many people while
while coming in with - at 12 wow you
guys are good
how many of you who know that the answer
is minus 1/12 think you really
understand why it comes to minus 1/12 or
you can give the argument I'd be
interested to see your answer on that
just say yes if you understand it and
know if you're a little bit shaking on
it but the reason I ask this is because
this is deeply connected to the
technical explanation for why there are
extra dimensions and string theories so
that's the kind of thing that we would
need to cover in order to give a full
answer to the extra dimensions in string
theory ok I see a lot of - 2/12 and some
are saying that they understand and some
are saying yes and Ramanuja n-- is uh no
dad teach us as Justin and in a
subsequent episode I will not try to do
it now
I know it's minus 1/12 and I know how
this comes about yes great perfect so so
some of you are quite advanced which is
fantastic some of you are saying that
you don't okay so I'm gonna jump over to
a different question now john smith ii
asks how do you derive the time that
inflationary expansion occurred for and
you may recall in the episode which repa
sowed was i think was the last one
number 30
well that was an inelegant sip of water
so glad that that's i'm on film so in
the episode number 30 I described how
this burst of repulsive gravity this
inflationary expansion just last for a
tiny fraction of a second I said it was
something like 10 to the minus 30 to 10
to the minus 33 seconds and the question
is what determines the duration of the
inflationary burst and the answer is
it's nothing fundamental so you may
recall that I put an inflationary
potential deify is what I called it and
via Phi I don't bother drawing it but
you recall it was a very gentle slope
and then it had a steeper section to the
curve and that
ensured that the value of the in photon
field would stay pretty constant for a
while and it's that constant value of
the energy and pressure densities that
yields they were pulse of gravity that
pushes everything apart but then the in
photon rolls down the field so the
question is how long does it stay on the
top part which is the span of time
during which the inflationary expansion
takes place and that's totally dependent
on the slope of that top part and the
length of that top part right is V of v
so how much does phi a have to change
before it hits that other part of the
curve in which it falls down and all
that's chosen by hand all that's chosen
by the physicist all that's chosen by
the definition of the model and once you
choose that definition of the model you
then work out how long the field stays
up on the hill and I noticed that half
of my heads being cut off so I'm gonna
shift this a little bit so that's that's
really the answer to to the question we
would love it if we had a fundamental
explanation where you could say from
first principles here's what the
potential looks like from first
principles here's how long the field
therefore will stay on that plateau from
first principles therefore here's how
long the inflationary bursts will last
and we can't do that yet so that's a
goal for the future maybe one of you
guys will figure out how to do that but
as of today it's all set by hand it is
not set by any fundamental principle
okay yeah teach our goal all loved you
in Startalk sir could there be a
component of the Higgs field in the time
dimension which is why we only travel
forward Wow well first yeah taste thank
you for the kind words on that Startalk
episode it was a lot of fun talking
about the end of time with my friends
over there at star talk
Neal but your question is um is an
interesting one a perplexing one so when
we talk about the Higgs field we do talk
about it filling space for a duration of
time so it really does fill a region of
space-time so I think you may be
imagining that the Higgs field only
talks to space and it doesn't have any
conversation if you will with the
temporal the time direction but that's
not true so for instance it's possible
in the very early universe that the
Higgs field did not fill space there are
many in fact the most common models
imagine that when you heat up the
universe sufficiently high the Higgs
field evaporates it goes away so the
early universe was so hot that in many
of these models there was no molasses
filling space there was no Higgs field
filling space which means at that moment
all the particles would have been
massless and then as the universe
expands and cools the idea is that the
Higgs field can condense kind of freeze
out if you will from the evaporated
environment and then from that point
forward space is filled with the Higgs
field so if you think about it that way
I think you'll recognize that the Higgs
already fills space and time in this
very specific way that I described so
we're not missing that possibility if I
if I didn't interpret your question
correctly do ask it again but I hope
that addresses it
ooh what happened I went away for a
minute I I must have missed must have
disappeared for a minute folks
I have no idea if you heard my answer I
just gave one of the best answers of my
life and I hope that no I assume that
you guys heard I don't know what
happened but anyway I think we're back
in business here which is good
Marin who you'd COO I'm gonna get this
coup Kendall Marin COO Kendall I love
you new book thank you appreciate that
always like kind words when you're
thinking about the end of our universe
in the far far future change if there
were proof of other universes and to
some extent it would affect my thinking
you you may recall and it was only a
brief mention but in in chapter chapter
10 I think it was chapter 10
toward the end yeah in chapter 10 toward
the end I do note this interesting
possibility that the wonderful creative
influential physicist Alexander the
Lincoln and his collaborator came
forward with some years ago where they
imagined the possibility that as our
civilization or more generally our
universe comes to an end maybe we could
pack up all of our knowledge and insight
into some kind of capsule and launch it
into another universe if the multi-verse
were real sort of send it out in space
and it could reach sufficiently distant
locations where those regions would not
suffer the same fate that we might be
suffering and that's an interesting
possibility it would it wouldn't change
my view on how reality would end in our
universe the part that we have direct
access to and and the environment that
we have been living within and measuring
and having a civilization on planet
Earth and so forth but at least
conceptually the idea that we might
launch our understanding into a distinct
realm that might last longer than us at
least gives us some kind of symbolic
carrying on I was gonna say symbolic
immortality but that's not quite true
because that other region will also have
a finite duration and what they show
though and this is the part that is
perhaps curious of all if there truly is
a multiverse then you can argue that
there is some region in fact many
reasons out there that will last
arbitrarily long through weird quantum
fluctuations that cut against the grain
of the likelihood is given by the
probabilistic mathematics you know if
something has a 1 million chance of
happening if you have enough universes
where every possibility takes place then
clearly there's gonna be some universe
and which then one and a million weird
possibility happens and sometimes the
one in a million or one in a billion and
one in a trillion weird possibility is
such that it will extend the duration of
life and consciousness in that universe
and yeah so that definitely slaps your
brain around a little bit maybe gives
you a little bit of comfort that even if
life and consciousness come to an end in
our universe there's some place it's
very abstract because you don't have
direct access to it but there's
someplace out there where life and mind
continue so do I take solace from that I
don't know number one I am a multiverse
skeptic some people like why would he
talk about man you're the guy that's
always talking about of the universes I
talk about other universes as an
interesting possibility I wrote a book
about it because I find that possibility
exciting interesting worthy of attention
but in that book and in any interview
where they don't cut out the caveats I
always say we need evidence we need
observation to establish that these
ideas are correct at the moment I view
them as a powerfully interesting tool in
our toolkit as you try to understand
things in the world
around us so you know with the recent
observations of those strange particles
sure bring out your toolkit and imagine
the possibility of other universes but
I'm a skeptic of this so in terms of
taking solace from this idea it feels
too too tentative for me to hang any
existential hope on the continuance of
life in mind in a parallel universe so
it doesn't really help me in that regard
in any deep way rather the approach I
take in the book does help me you know
when I recognize how unlikely it is that
we're here when I recognize how
spectacular it is that particle is
governed by physical law can do the
things that we do that to me lessens the
blow of realizing that life in mind in
our universe are finite that's what
works for me thank you for the question
though of course all right what else we
have here
she Creole asked the Supreme please
explain the equivalence principle well
hmm and then the question about
particles accelerating space creating
curvature and so forth you see the
equivalence principle is the heart of
Einstein's general theory of relativity
the way that I like to think about it is
that a sufficient ly well chosen
accelerated trajectory can either Mach
up a gravitational force or cancel a
gravitational force the example that I
gave in one of the earlier episodes I
can't really do it here you know I did
this thing with a bottle of water this
is glass somebody got mad at me for
having plastic bottles last time so I
listened to you guys so here is a glass
bottle but imagine it had holes in it
which you can do in a plastic bottle
if the water therefore would be spraying
out of the holes if I'm holding it like
this and I noted if you recall that if
you let this go into freefall
accelerating downward from my
perspective the mat is able to cancel
out the pull of gravity on the water to
the water stop spraying out of the holes
accelerated motion cancelling out the
force of gravity
Einstein's version of this was the
painter who fell off a ladder and while
descending in that accelerated
trajectory from our perspective toward
the surface of the earth that painter
doesn't feel his or her own weight I
ain't if the painters on a scale the
scale Falls with the painters feet so
the painters no longer pressing down on
the scale and so the reading on the
scale goes to zero so that's beautiful
that's a beautiful unexpected link
between accelerated motion and gravity
in this case accelerated motion
canceling out gravity and what Einstein
emphasized and I described in earlier
episode the reverse is also true
accelerated motion upwards say in space
if you're standing say on the platform
and someone accelerates things so that
the platform is pushing up against your
feet if the acceleration is the right
magnitude you'll think
that you're standing on planet Earth
it'll feel like the force of gravity so
it's this equivalence between
accelerated motion and the force of
gravity and this is what was critical to
Einstein being able to work out the
general theory of relativity now
something occurred to me as we were
talking about that oh yeah here's the
point that I wanted to make so
oftentimes we talk about Newton in the
Apple right Newton is sitting under the
tree the Apple falls hits him in the
head and the idea is that that kind of
inspires or at least as the story goes
that inspired Newton in understanding
the force of gravity in the Einsteinian
description it's completely different
right yang steinem description the state
of freefall is the natural state of
existence that's the one where the body
doesn't feel a gravitational force the
painter does not feel his own way or her
own weight or their own weight during
the descent the water doesn't come out
of the holes of the bottle because the
water no longer feels its own weight so
the natural state of being is freefall
and therefore the natural perspective in
the apple hitting Newton on the head is
not Newton's perspective he's not in
freefall
he's on planet earth he's not falling
it's the apples perspective so the story
of the Newton Apple from the apples
perspective is the Apple detaches from
the tree the tree accelerates upwards
the apple looks down and sees Newton's
head approaching it and Newton's head
slams into the Apple that's the
description of that famous story from
the more natural perspective of the body
in freefall which in this case is the
Apple okay carry on on
Alexes so that means we are all gods I'm
not sure gods what so if you want to
clarify that I'd be happy to answer it
pry out - who's also here as a regular
thank you God I'm happy to see the
regular participants your podcasting
star talk was really knowledgeable thank
you but I have a doubt
can we interpret the notion of quantum
entanglement - the stitch fabric of
space and time so so so look prior you
should have a doubt
nobody right now is saying that we
really understand what the fabric of
space-time is made of we use the
language all the time
Einstein either used exactly that
language in the German perhaps or
something equivalent this notion that
there is a stuff out there that can warp
and curve and using the idea of a fabric
is a nice poetic way of talking about it
but what really is the fabric made of
people to ask that for a long time and
what I find exciting is that at least
now we have some proposals some
strategies for how to go about
addressing that question and quantum
entanglement is one of the most fruitful
strategies that have been pursued again
quantum entanglement tells us that
distant particles are connected if
they're set up in the right way with
kind of threads of quantum entanglement
in an earlier episode I made them these
yellow threads or I didn't make him
these yellow threads Josh Zimmerman made
them these yellow threads who's actually
behind the scenes right now making sure
that all this is working spectacularly
creative editor and animator but anyway
so we have these yellow threads between
the particles and that allows them to
correlate their behaviors now when you
think about that
distant particles connected by a thread
of quantum physics you began to wonder
could it be that space itself is
stitched by these threads of quantum
entanglement and there is now
mathematical might behind that idea
people like well many people have been
involved in this idea from many Susskind
to one maldacena mark from roms doc many
many people we had a program a full
program at the World Science Vessel so
if you want to have a disc and you know
what we're gonna do it again a more
refined version of that program this
summer we're gonna have a program on
quantum entanglement and wormholes and
stitching the fabric of space-time so so
we'll go into it much more detail there
but I would say Priok that having doubt
that that is the right way of thinking
about space that it is a fabric stitch
by the threads of quantum entanglement
have doubt but have an open mind and
let's allow the research to progress and
let's see where it goes because honestly
I'm shocked that we even have ideas that
are sufficiently well formulated for
mathematical analysis regarding the
fabric of space and what it's made of I
wouldn't have thought that in my
lifetime frankly we'd be able to make
progress on that and the fact that there
are some real interesting possibilities
that people are pursuing that to me is
the big story whether it's the right
explanation I don't know but the big
story is that we can actually begin to
address these questions with a degree of
mathematical seriousness and that's very
very impressive so let's see so a couple
people are asking about wormholes maybe
because I mentioned it Abu Bakar Faruk
we asks professor Bremen was the
likelihood of the existence of
intergalactic wormholes and then right
underneath that Gayatri Pandit asks do
you think quantum entanglement can make
travelling through wormholes possible
all interesting questions number one
there is zero evidence for the existence
of any wormholes whatsoever
no events all right it is an idea that
naturally emerges from Einstein's
general relativity you can solve the
field equations with certain assumptions
and come up with these shapes that have
this tunnel-like quality this throat
like quality Einstein himself in a paper
with Nathan rose in 1935 wrote down one
of the early solutions of this form so
the math allows for it does that mean
that these entities are real well you
remember what Einstein said Tula maitre
your calculations are correct but your
physics is abominable
he was talking about the expanding
universe in that example and there
Einstein was dead wrong physics was not
abominable now you could say the same
thing about wormholes
they naturally come out of calculations
entrenched within the general theory of
relativity but not every mathematical
solution is realized in the real world I
think and therefore you have to have
real observational evidence and we do
not have any now could quantum mechanics
help make wormholes traversable and the
answer to that is yes so when you create
mathematically a wormhole you then often
investigate its properties and
scientists have found that they tend to
collapse in on themselves such that it
be very difficult if not impossible for
something to pass through however people
have found that if there's an exotic
form of matter that has a negative
energy density sorry excuse me
ate too much for lunch negative energy
density then that matter can create an
outward force that can keep the throat
the tunnel part of a wormhole open and
that yields what's known as a
traversable wormhole now again we don't
know if wormholes are real so we don't
know if traversable wormholes are real
but at least the math does allow for
quantum mechanics to yield a kind of
substance that would keep a wormhole
propped open so a lot of tentative
things in that sentence but the bottom
line is at least mathematically speaking
mathematically speaking I don't know if
this is in the real world you can in
principle have wormholes that would be
traversable that you could pass through
and you know that's pretty exciting
because if you had a traversable
wormhole you can turn it into a time
machine you move the openings of a
traversable wormhole relative to each
other put one near the edge of a black
hole one far away time elapses at
different rates at the two openings of
the wormhole makng have a tunnel with
two openings and you're somehow able to
make time elapse at different
that the two openings of the tunnel that
means as you pass through the tunnel
you'll start at one moment in time but
you can end up in a very different
moment of time either in the future or
in the past and that's why these ideas
are shocking and strange some would say
that's proof that you'll never have a
traversable wormhole because you can't
travel to the Past some would say I
think it's too quick but nevertheless it
would be monumental if there is any real
evidence for any of these wormhole ideas
to be actually real hmm Marilyn Kozak so
many questions but hoping your back is
feeling better Mountain thank you you
must have seen the interview with Joe
Rogan where at the end he nicely
inquired I guess why I was sitting in
such a strange angle no no we'd spoken
about beforehand that's what it is I was
of course I showed up there on crutches
now it's all coming back to me
and so Joe had various suggestions in
fact he actually took me after the
interview to his his workout stations
right in the same space where we we did
the conversation and he put me on all
sorts of machines and I have to say that
was the beginning of the road to
recovery for me you know so then he also
suggested all sorts of treatments it was
really great really nice guy but yes the
answer is my back is is feeling much
better so you know you talk about you
know a life of contemplation thinking
about the universe and math and physics
if your back is hurting or you've got
any physical ailment it all goes away
you can't do anything you can't think
about anything else if the pain is great
so man we we are these creatures whose
brains can soar to the edge of the
cosmos but you fiddle with us physically
and you break a little something or you
imbalance in the chemical makeup and
that's it we fall apart
we are just these bags of particles how
amazing that when they're doing the
right thing we can engage with the world
in such deeply interesting and profound
ways okay what else do we have to talk
about here
um Philip asks if time is not
fundamental where is the point that it
emerges from from more basic principles
and how can the universe evolved from a
fundamentally timeless basis and I wish
I had something good to say on that but
let me just give a couple of quick
thoughts we are familiar with qualities
of the world that you might have thought
to be fundamental but they're not
refined investigation and knowledge
shows us that these qualities of the
world emerge from more fundamental
starting points in the example that I I
like to give it's very intuitive is
temperature you know there is a time
when you might have thought in the
history of our understanding I'm we here
is now the entire species there's a time
when we would have thought that hot and
cold to these fundamental qualities of
the world but then physicists chemists
dig deeper and they realize oh
temperature that's nothing but a measure
of the average kinetic energy of the
particles that make up a substance
whether that be the environment the air
or that be you know a pan that we're
holding right and if the molecules are
moving very quickly in the handle of
that pan and you grab it you scald and
you burn your flesh hot if on the other
hand the molecules are moving much more
slowly you grab it and it feels
comfortable so temperature hot and cold
is now recognized to emerge from a more
fundamental idea the motions of the
particles that make up a substance could
it be as people have kicked around and
as Philip is asking that time is also
emergent could it be that there are more
fundamental qualities of the world I
don't know what to call the molecules of
time atoms of time people use this
language but really making that precise
is difficult but imagine that there are
these particles that only when they
arrange themselves in a particular
configuration not moving quickly or
slowly that's tempered
but rather arranging themselves in the
right pattern when they do that a
concept of time emerges just like when
the particles are in the arrange the
moving quickly the concept of hot
emerges could that be it and could it be
therefore that when the particles of
time are not arranged in that
configuration time as we know it doesn't
exist so to answer your question Philip
imagine imagine a universe hard to do is
our language is so temporal from the
get-go it's difficult for me to even
talk about things without time slipping
in but imagine a time there it is
long ago another reference to time when
the universe was in a configuration in
which those particles were not arranged
in the manner that yields the
conventional notion of time and then at
some moment a temporal notion has
slipped in again at some moment the
particles do arrange in the manner that
yields conventional notions of time and
then the universe progresses from there
now I don't have the language to even
talk about the era prior to the
particles arranging in a manner that
yields time but intuitively I think you
can grasp the idea that there could have
been a realm where time had not yet
emerged and only when the particles
coalesced in the right way that sounds
like a temporal process there you go I'm
slipping in again but somehow when the
particles coalesce in the right way time
emerges so you see the challenge is to
develop a completely different
vocabulary and a completely different
mathematical structure that allows us to
talk about processes without time
creeping in and people have worked on
this people have worked on versions of
physics where there isn't time and space
from the outset rather there's the
relationships between the ingredients
I've never been completely convinced
that those approaches have achieved what
they seek to achieve but it's just to
say that people do try to develop the
language and the math to make more
precise the answer that I just gave but
I hope that gives you some feel
for how time could be emergent and how
the universe itself could have an era in
which time as we know it did not exist
so Rajeev dar asks linear or cyclic
cosmology and I would say I fear
strongly toward linear cosmology right
now I have been struck over decades as
have many of my colleagues by the
successes of the inflationary theory I
am NOT saying as I noted in the episode
I feel again was episode 30 I'm not
saying that inflation has been proven I
am saying that it's a very compelling
framework for dealing with a great
number of cosmological issues and giving
rise to a very economical compact
description of how the universe got to
be the way it currently is now there are
critics of the inflationary theory
including the one of the gentleman who
was responsible for the theory itself
Paul Steinhardt
and again as I emphasized in the earlier
episode I think it's spectacular that
Paul who developed a theory is willing
to take a sledgehammer to it to try to
break it down and suggest an alternative
possibility doesn't mean that he's right
it does mean that there's a vibrant
conversation that would not otherwise be
happening if Paul and his colleagues
were not developing these alternate
ideas in the end of the day it's got to
be observation and experiment
mathematical consistency the predictions
that emerge from a theory that
determines whether it's the linear
version of inflation or Paul's
suggestion as others have worked on to a
cyclic cosmology of bouncing cosmology
so we will see I would think that in the
next 5-10 years we will have enough new
mathematical insight enough new data
that we'll be able to answer your
question more forcefully but at the
moment there are these competing
proposals I think the vast majority the
cosmologists are in the linear camp but
that could change over time ok let's see
what else let's see
okay that's interesting so I get any
inspector Levin says I'm the original
Ludwig van bond Beethoven I don't think
original in this ends I've got original
but probably original in specific count
and there have been copycats Wow
and then you've been put out oh wow I
don't know all sorts of political
intrigue happening on the live chat so I
have not much to say about that but
hopefully everybody's having a good time
that's all that really matters all right
on to other questions
easy Sparky does the future already
exist right now certainly in in
Einstein's special relativity if you
allow me to answer this from the
perspective back in the early part of
20th century back then I think Einstein
would have had a certain degree of
warmth and sympathy and agreement in
that view that the future already exists
well I should not have chosen this
bottle I just got water all over my face
just excuse me one second as I wipe
ma'am I'm gonna get a better cup out
here anyway I was trying not to use a
plastic bottle but you know Einstein's
view is that the whole notion of now
right the whole notion of what's
happening at a given moment in time is
highly in the eye of the person they
observer the beholder because if you and
I are moving relative to each other we
have different clocks ticking off at
different rates we have different
notions of simultaneity in that episode
I don't remember what it was it was a
while back now but there was a your
daily equation on the relativity of
simultaneity where if you watch that or
if you go back to it if you're
interested I established that in the
special theory of relativity we learned
that things that I say happen at one
moment in time if you're moving with
respect to me you will not agree that
those events happen at the same moment
in time right we're like right now
I would say I snapped my fingers
simultaneously at the same moment but if
you were moving relative to me in one or
another direction and you observe those
snaps from your perspective you would
say what happened was snap snap or if
you're moving the other way you'll say
what happened is snap snap so the notion
of simultaneity what's in the present
depends upon your state of motion and
that's exciting and interesting in its
own right but one implication is that
you and I if we don't agree on the now
we don't agree on the past and therefore
we also don't agree in the future right
the person moving by would have said
that happened first and then in the
future this happened the person moving
the other direction would say this
happened first and then this happened in
the future while I say that happened at
the same moment so observers in relative
motion mix up their conceptions of past
present and future and therefore the
things that I consider to take place in
my future that's a real motion I have a
unassailable conception of the past I
have an unassailable conception of the
future but it's my future and my past
and things that are in my future can be
in your present or can be in your past
depending on how you're moving relative
to me and if my future can be in your
past then in a sense my futures already
taken place now when you look at this
really closely many of the things that
then come to mind are not possible it's
not like you can learn about my future
before I know about it and tell me about
no no can't happen
none of those games can be played
because it takes time for you to learn
about what happened in my future even if
it's in your past it takes time for the
signal to reach you right when I look
out at the distant stars I'm seeing the
past it took a long time for that light
to travel to my eyes so I'm seeing
something a long time ago but by
time I am aware of it it's long past
it's long gone and therefore has none of
the funny things that might come to mind
in terms of spoiling causality or
possible but in an abstract sense is the
future already in existence yeah
according to special relativity it is
quantum mechanics generativity
interesting nuances complications if
you're interested ask about it I'm happy
to go down but this according to that
way of thinking about special relativity
the future in some sense is already real
so let's see I'm going to take a risk
and try to drink some more particularly
thirsty today what do we got here
well so divyam single asks I just wanted
to ask what your viewpoint of m-theory
it's progress since 1995 how does it
explain dark energy and look my view is
this I've said this before I'm happy to
say it again I am thrilled in the rate
of progress and string theory or
m-theory in certain kinds of questions I
mentioned one before that insight into
the fabric of space-time may be stitched
by the threads of quantum entanglement
that ultimately relies on insights from
string theory that's great some of the
insights into black holes that string
theory has yielded spectacular some of
the insights into pure mathematics that
have come from string theory my own
contribution I'm happy to a
participating mirror symmetry and
topology change these are exciting
developments what we have not done is
make contact with observation and
experiment in the manner that we hoped
would happen by today so anybody who's a
research scientist that's listening to
this anyone who's a graduate student
who's in the middle of their
dissertation the research program will
know you can't predict how long it's
going to take you can't predict what
area of science is going to develop
rapidly and what area of science is
going to develop at a snail's pace
if you interviewed me as a graduate
student back in the 1980s I would have
thought that by today
we'd only made contact with the
supersymmetric particles that string
theory requires or that would have seen
some exotic process that would give
indirect evidence for string theory that
has not happened but again if you ask me
back in the 1980s will we be able to
talk about what makes up the threads of
the space-time fabric or will we be able
to truly understand the entropy count
for black holes I would have said I
don't think so it's gonna take longer
and yet we've gotten headway made
progress in these areas so unbalanced
it's exactly what you'd expect the rate
of progress of science is unpredictable
as long as it is making progress in some
areas that means that theory is alive
well and
healthy and I think that's the best that
I can do in describing the state of play
in string theory okay all right what
have we got here
they may switch over to YouTube for a
second as there are some that I remember
over there liking a lot all right so one
one technical question I think it's
worth spending ten seconds on from
Martin tope inca why do people use the
via five plot with a rolling ball in the
direction of the gradient of the
potential and not Phi of T plot to
describe inflation and and so what what
Martin is referring to is my head's on
the blink right now so I can't draw it
for you but you remember I mentioned
before ready
I drew this curve that was the plot of V
as a function of Phi or maybe this is
the direction I drew it that's probably
how I drew it and I imagine that the Phi
value was like a ball that's metaphor
but it's a ball in the sense that it's
value changes over time and rolls down
the hill and the reason why we typically
write Phi of T is that it via Phi we
could do five T you're absolutely right
five starts at a certain value it stays
constant at that value over a stretch of
time and then it drops down the reason
why we frame in terms of via Phi is via
Phi is what we choose and put into the
model that's the user chosen quality of
that model of cosmology we then use via
fine to write down the equations that
determine how Phi changes in time so Phi
of T for us is generally a derived
quantity whereas V of Phi is a quantity
that we put in by hand so we tend to
define the model by the things that we
put into it
and then we extract from it through
calculation certain qualities and that's
why we write down the thing that we pick
by hand and then we figure out Phi of T
we determine it
by solving the equations of motion so
that's that's but you're right you can
you can do it either way
doesn't matter okay so van wrong says
dr. green huge fan of your work thank
you van Ron can you recommend a great
book on the history of quantum mechanics
yeah a great book on the history of
quantum mechanics I dunno some I'm
having trouble bringing them into mind
directly right now
it's on the tip of my tongue that's why
I'm struggling to it there's a book
called quantum and there's one word
after it quantum ages quantum yeah it
hopefully it'll come to me but there
there are a lot of really good books on
the on the subject not I understand
you're asking for the history as opposed
to the extra subtly I'm gonna have to
come back to it hopefully it will come
to me or maybe believe and put it I'll
put it in the comments if it comes to me
later ok so Oh what if we go to the odd
abide choco asks does a particle without
mass would it could it be motionless and
the answer to that is no it's a strange
idea if a particle doesn't have any mass
it cannot sit still
I successfully took a sip of water Wow
congratulate me don't have water in my
face on that one a particle that has
zero mass is a particle that will always
and forever be traveling at the speed of
light so the photon of course is the
prototypical example and the proton
opposite photon that proton the photon
the particle of light is always
traveling at light speed it's never not
traveling at light speed and you know
there's a lot of intuitive ways you can
think about it you know as a as a
particle gets ever lighter obviously the
wispy 'us force will give it the largest
of accelerations right F equals MA fix
of small value of F let em go smaller
and smaller the acceleration is F over m
as M goes to zero the acceleration goes
infinite infinity goes to infinity and
therefore the particle accelerates
arbitrarily quickly more specifically
when you really look at RN Stein special
theory of relativity it is the
trajectories of masses particles that
define the causal structure of the
universe they are the ones that set the
limit on how quickly a signal can travel
from one point in the universe to
another and therefore they delineate
what influences any given process can
exert on other events and so the the
speed of light is an interesting concept
because we name it the speed of light
because it is the speed of light but
it's more than that
the specialty of relativity is not so
much about the speed of light per se as
is about the causal connections the
events that can influence each other by
any kind of signal sent with any kind of
particle light being one particle but
gravitons masses particles that we
believe exist would also be traveling at
the speed of light or call it speed of
gravity as with any massless particle
they all fall into the same category of
articles that cannot be motionless
always traveling at 1:00 in the same
fixed speed okay
we got here al-bayan as I've read once
there's a mathematical relationship
between dividing by zero and black holes
is it true well sort of not really I
mean not in any deep sense when you look
at the solution to Einstein's equations
and the general theory of relativity and
you look at the amount of curvature at
the origin at the zero point say of your
coordinate system for a black hole you
find that the curvature explodes it gets
arbitrarily big and depending on the
exact solution you're looking at it goes
like a power of your distance from the
origin so imagine it's the sixth power
that the curvature goes like one over R
to the sixth power for the black hole
solution then as R goes to zero one over
zero to the six is zero so it's like
dividing one by zero so the curvature at
the origin of a black hole is like
dividing by zero but that's the nature
of a certain kind of curvature
singularity that need not be associated
with a black hole it could be associated
with you know any solution as some would
say you know aren't aren't singularities
always cloaked with a black hole horizon
and if that's the Association you have
in mind that's that's fine that's true
but I guess why my gut reaction say yes
and no is there is some quip I don't
know if it was Stephen right or comedian
or maybe it was Einstein or somebody
like that I don't know don't quote me on
this quote but somebody said black holes
are the result of God dividing by zero
and when I hear it framed in that way as
you no doubt can tell by the look on my
face it's funny clever perhaps but
there's nothing more than that to the
statement so I think my interpretation
of the curvature going to infinity at
the origin of the coordinate grid for
black hole solutions probably the best
real connection between / 0 and black
holes that you can get
so DM asks and is very excited about
this question so exclamation points says
even though things can perceive the same
event at a different time
isn't there an absolute time that an
event happened and and the answer to
that is is no your intuition says that
DM exclamation point question mark but
your intuition is something that we've
learned from Einstein is a generally a
poor guide to understanding the true
nature of reality so really what
Einstein taught us is that there is no
universal notion of time so an event can
take place and you may use a notion of
simultaneity to determine when that
event happens what do I mean the
firecracker goes off and you look at
your watch you're like okay it went off
at 12 noon and you're saying that those
two events are simultaneous that's what
it means to say that an event happened
at 12 noon
you mean the event happened at my watch
struck twelve simultaneous events that's
what I mean by the event took place at
12 noon but as I described before
different observers moving relative to
you will not say that those two events
were simultaneous they will say either
that your clock struck noon before the
firecracker exploded or they will say
that the firecracker exploded and then
your clock struck 12 noon and so the
conception of when an event took place
depends upon who is doing the observing
who's doing the measuring the clocks and
the state of motion that they are
undergoing why does that matter
why does that matter why is it matter
because it radically changes our
perspective of the world our view of the
world according to Isaac Newton was
there's this Universal clock ticking out
there in some metaphorical abstract way
and the events of the universe simply
unfold as that clock ticks off time
forward and because the clock
Universal you and I and everybody else
will agree on when events take place and
what Einstein did is he took a
sledgehammer and he smashed the
universal Newtonian clock and the shards
that shot through space are the
individual clocks that each and every
observer carries with themselves and so
time now is not universal time is in the
eye of the observer a completely
different perspective on how the world
works I mean don't you find it
mind-blowing that if you and I diem
imagine you and I on opposite ends of
the universe billions of light-years
apart and let's say initially we're not
moving relative to each other which
means we will agree on what things
happen at the same moment but then if I
get up and I start to walk toward you or
away from you my conception of what
happens right now may swing a hundreds
of years into your past or hundreds of
years into your future things that you
would say have not yet occurred I would
say are you kidding me they already
occurred things that you would say our
long past that's a no-no they just
happened right now that's crazy sounding
but it's true that's why it matters
that's what Einstein's relativity of
simultaneity gives us okay
Chetan asks is it true the photons do
not experience time and this question
comes up now and then and I ask you to
think about your question a little bit
so you say photons do not experience
time normally I don't need to parse a
question carefully but this one I do
because what does it mean for a photon
to experience something we
anthropomorphize the particles of the
world and we imagine that they kind of
have some experience of time like we do
some conception of time passing and
that's not true I don't think I don't
think photons have any conscious
awareness so the question of time
passing for them is a very different
proposition from the notion of time
passing for us and therefore I always
find it a little uncomfortable to answer
this question as if it were the case
that a photon is consciously aware now
why do I say that I say that because yes
poetically speaking there is a sense in
which if a photon did have conscious
awareness it couldn't experience the
passage of time in a sense that it's
clock would be dead fixed at one moment
relative to our clock or said
differently from its perspective it
would see time on our clock elapsed
infinitely quickly all events would
happen at the same moment so the notion
of the photons being able to see the
world as we'd like to see it events
happen one after another after another
with some finite separation in time
between the events that would not be the
photons experience but I urge you to
take this with a grain of salt because
photons don't have that experience
whatsoever and therefore if it excites
you and you finally interesting to think
about how the world looks from the
perspective of a photon beam I guess
it's fun to play those games but don't
take it too seriously because no
conscious awareness is ever going to
have the perspective of a photon
okay what do we got going on here yes a
garden asks again so what would a photon
see in its one moment again I'd say the
same caveat I don't even know what it
means for a photon to see has it seen
with another photon another photon
brings the image of light to the eyeball
of the photon the fruit you know so you
see we get into a bit muddled very
quickly putting all that to the side
which I shouldn't do but just because
you asked and that's an unsatisfying
kind of answer in some sense the photon
would see all of space in the direction
that it's moving infinitely compressed
right because it's going at the speed of
light which means the gamma factor would
be infinite so distances that it looks
at whatever the heck that means would be
infinitely compressed and moreover
because it's clock is ticking off the
infinitely slow compared to the clocks
that it's moving by if we see those
clocks ticking off you know at a rate of
time that would be very strange you know
so I it's hard it's hard to really it's
hard to really answer this question you
know as a wheat we can talk about our
view of the photon our view the photon
is that if it were carrying a watch that
watch would be ticking infinitely slowly
you can say that but the real way to
answer that question is don't talk about
photons talk about a particle traveling
at ninety nine point nine nine nine nine
nine nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine nine nine nine percent of speed of
light that's pretty darn close to the
speed of light but not exactly equal to
the speed of light none small difference
is kind of vital because that is a
perspective that in principle a particle
or even a human being can be within I
mean if a particle is traveling at that
speed in the opposite direction from its
perspective whatever that means I am
traveling this way at that high fraction
of the speed of light and again we know
what happens in those circumstances I
look at your watch see it going slow you
look at my watch I see it going slow you
know so so those are the things that you
know if I look at an object moving by me
I see it compressed in the direction of
motion so that if an object
is moving by me an incredibly high speed
close to speed of light it will be like
a pancake twisted pancake as it turns
out so these are the things that we can
say but really thinking about the
perspective of a photon always is going
to get you into trouble
you know Niels Bohr was famously fond of
saying that if you ask a question that
refers to a quality of the world that it
is impossible fundamentally impossible
for you to ever access then you're
likely to find that your attempt to
understand it is going to hit a brick
wall and that's this perspective of a
photon you can talk about it
you can poetically think about it but
you can't ever access it and therefore
when you head down that trajectory it's
a dangerous one to take seriously
our Yong Tiwari asked hey prof love the
quantum series what is nothingness the
probability of you seeing this is 1 522
1 in 526 right now apparently so look at
that you've won the lottery
yeah I'm sure you'd rather have won the
real lottery over this one but so what
is nothingness subtle question you
wouldn't think so
nothingness is the absence of stuff stop
right we should stop right there but the
problem is you have to carefully
delineate which stuff you are imagining
being absent sure if you imagine that
material object you know like my contact
lens box and you know my water bottle if
all of that kind of stuff was gone you'd
have a certain kind of nothingness
you'd have emptiness empty space but
space would still be there time would
still be there and if you look really
closely in the quantum description even
the fluctuations of the fundamental
fields would be there the electric field
magnetic field all bubbling around in
the quantum vacuum so that doesn't all
of a sudden seemed like nothingness at
all that seems like a whole lot of
something it's just not the usual some
things from everyday experience so then
you want to go further and say can I
really imagine a nothing that doesn't
even have any space no time a true
nothing and you can imagine that and
it's something that imprints of all you
can write down a mathematical formalism
that would make use of you know it's a
it's a spatial manifold if you'll read
the size of the manifold they shrunk all
the way to zero so the space-time itself
has gone away it's not that it's
shrunken within a environment which is
itself got the qualities of space and
time
we're actually imagining all of
space-time itself you know the
cosmological solutions where you wind
the film
those guys are getting smaller and
smaller and not in an existing realm but
the realm itself is disappearing so you
can approach the ideas of nothingness
but it is a surprisingly subtle and
curious idea if you want to have a full
look at it we have a from time to time I
do this just as I think it's interesting
for you to look at things there is a
World Science Festival program called
what is nothingness or what is nothing
or the meaning of nothing or something
like that and it is the parsing of the
conception of nothing from various
distinct points of view and it's
interesting to see how different ways of
approaching that question yield
different answers Amanda asks can you
elaborate on the different types of
infinities yes you know I should do a
whole episode on your daily equation on
the different kinds of infinities the
two that are most prominent easy to
understand are the infinity that we all
use when we were kids you know 1 2 3 4 5
you know the various incarnations of
that you know you you you you say
something against and they say well I
twice on you 3 times 4 you know you have
this bickering going on and only if some
one kid is always going to jump to
infinity to try to win the argument and
that's one type of infinity just
counting the natural numbers 1 2 3 4 5
up to infinity but you can ask yourself
how does that infinity compare to the
infinity that also allows decimals and
fractions point 1 2 4 1 3 9 7 5 9 and so
on or PI you know that's a decimal
3.14159265 goes on I can't go any
further than that many of you can beat
me in that no doubt
so the infinity of the counting numbers
versus the infinities of the decimal
numbers is an interesting question to
ask yourself and you can prove that the
Infinity associated with the counting
numbers is a smaller infinity
a small infant it's like a weird idea
he'd say well infinities infinity right
but you can ask yourself can you partner
up all of the counting numbers with all
of the decimal numbers so you say let me
call one the number of point zero one
two six let me call two point zero one
two nine and so on you try to pair them
up and you can prove that you will run
out of the counting numbers and when you
try to marry them in that pairwise
fashion they'll be left over decimals
that don't have a whole number partner
in that kind of attempted pairing and
the beautiful argument that comes from
Cantor Cantor's diagonal argument and
I'll do that in an episode at some point
maybe if I find the time to do it I
would love to do that but you should
look that up because it's a very simple
argument and kind of mind blowing Cantor
tries to line up the whole numbers in
the manner that I just said with the
decimals and he's able to prove the
existence of a decimal that will not be
partnered with a whole number and
therefore that the decimals have a
larger cardinality a larger infinity
than the counting numbers and they're
various games further that you can play
with this and get various levels of
infinity very curious very puzzling idea
but one that is very powerful and very
interesting all right so
what else do we have going on here yes
thank you
Brian DeGraw was the book quantum
generations it was quantum generations
that's exactly the book that I had in
mind I haven't looked at it in a long
time but I remember thinking that it did
a very nice job on the history of
quantum mechanics so we just
crowd-sourced the answer I used up one
of my lifelines to get Brian DeGraw to
chime in with the correct answer to the
question about a good book on the
history of quantum mechanics oh thank
you
Steve Baggins hello greetings from
Greece can you explain the function of
the Z boson and sure when people were
trying to understand the basic forces of
nature obviously we knew about gravity
for a long long time we knew about
electricity and magnetism for a long
time
Maxwell and Faraday and others gave us a
deeper description of electricity and
magnetism that blended them into a
unified whole called the electromagnetic
force and in the early part well the
middle part of the 20th century people
began to go further to describe the
nuclear forces not gravity not
electricity not magnetism but the
nuclear forces at work inside the nuclei
of atoms for the most part and there is
a force called the weak nuclear force
that was discovered experimentally and
understood theoretically in a handful of
papers but ultimately the ones that won
the Nobel Prize is the paper of glass
sheldon glashow from 61 and the paper in
66 67 by abdus salam and another paper
by Steven Weinberg and in this so-called
electroweak theory we recognize that the
weak nuclear force is transmitted not by
one particle the way the electromagnetic
force is so the electromagnetic force
light is communicated by photons one
type of particle the weak nuclear force
is transmitted by three types of
particles and those particles are called
the W plus the W - and the Z 0 or the Z
boson so what is the Z boson the Z boson
is one of the three particles that
transmits the weak nuclear force it is
the only particle of the three that
doesn't carry any electric charge so
whereas the W plus plus charge W -
negative charge they carry the weak
force and also they have electric charge
so the electromagnetic force
right in there blended with them the Z
is the weak nuclear force carrier that
does not also carry the electromagnetic
force the electric charge of it is zero
thanks for that question from Greece
so Mohit asks if we assume that the
guiding wave is real for a quantum
particle is it possible to not get the
interference pattern when we don't see a
flash in the photon and electron
interacting somehow I understand the
first half of the question I'm not fully
appreciating the second half so I'll
take a stab at it there's an episode in
your daily equation it is the mystery
episode episode 24 in episode 24 I
discussed the approach to quantum
mechanics called the Dubrow Bohm theory
and at the very end of that episode I
was rushing and it made one little
mistake in an equation I wrote down none
of you caught it but I was so
uncomfortable with this little mistake I
probably should have left it that I took
the episode down and I was gonna redo it
or fix it and haven't gotten around to
doing it but this question is associated
with that theory because in that theory
in the debris Bohm theory it's not as in
traditional quantum mechanics where we
say you've got a particle or you have a
wave right and you have both of those
blend it in some strange manner but when
you observe the entity using equipment
that's sensitive to its particle
qualities you only see the particle
aspect of the wave and the particle
aspect of the entity I should say and
when you're using equipment that's
sensitive to the wave-like qualities of
the entity then you only see the
wave-like qualities in the debris boom
theory that's not the case it's not
particle or wave it's particle and wave
because the wave function in quantum
mechanics the probability wave in
quantum mechanics in the dubrow Bohm
Theory it's a real thing it is the
guiding wave in the language that Mohit
is using so you've got particles moving
around and you got these quantum way
and the quantum way simply push the
particle around and they push the
particle around in an unusual manner a
manner that the theory postulates and
the manner that it pushes the particle
around can yield and does yield the
interference patterns of quantum double
slit experiment so the double slit
experiment in this approach is not
described in the usual way of the wave
for the particle goes through the two
slits it overlaps yields an interference
pattern and then when the wave hits the
screen it turns into a particle because
it's being detected by a detective it's
sensitive to particles and that forces
the wave-like nature to go away and the
particle-like nature too appears a dot
on the screen and that gives you the
interference pattern in the debris bone
theory you've got particles going right
from the gun through the openings and
hitting the detector screen and there
are particles through and through
through the entire journey in fact you
can plot their entire trajectory it's
not as though when you think about them
as particles going through one slit or
another the interference pattern
disappears as it traditionally does in
the usual story rather the wave the
quantum wave also in addition to the
particle goes through the two slits it
interferes with itself giving the
overlapping interference pattern and
that particular wave configuration
pushes the particles to accumulate where
the wave is big and not to accumulate
where the wave is small and that gives
you the band like structure on the
interference screen so it's a it's a
cooler well not a cooler it's a more
understandable explanation of the double
slit experiment it's less mysterious
than the usual explanation it allows
particles to have positions and speeds
it just augments the influences under
which the particles are subject the
influence of this new guiding wave comes
into the story so you might say well why
don't people talk about this theory
that's an interesting sociological
question I think the only physics part
of it is this theory is manifestly
non-local all right quantum entanglement
has a non-local quality already but it's
kind of hidden it's not in the
mathematical formalism that you start
with it kind of emerges later on that
there can be B states that have these
long-range correlations but the
fundamental Schrodinger equation that
you start with doesn't have any
nonlocality in it in the dubrow Bohm
theory the fundamental equation does
have nonlocality in it from the get-go
so the nonlocality is more in-your-face
and that has troubled many people I
don't really know why it's some deep
level because if the theory has
nonlocality in it who cares whether it's
like in your face from the get-go or
emerges downstream when you recognize
that certain states exhibit non-local
correlations be that as it may the
Dubrow Bohm theory is hardly spoken of
even though it allows you to still talk
about particle trajectories and particle
speeds and positions Wow quantum
mechanics in which particles have
positions and speeds easier in some
sense to grok to understand to wrap your
mind around and yet it has not caught on
and is not something that people for the
most part take seriously although there
are some wonderful receipts researchers
around the world who are developing the
subject further and happened for decades
and who knows how all play out
maybe physics class is a hundred years
from now we'll be focusing upon the Bohm
dubrow theory because that one has been
developed and that one wins out and I
should say the Bohm Dubrow theory
doesn't have a quantum measurement
problem when you measure a particle you
find it here it was here and is here
it's not as though it was in all these
other places and then it materialized
they're responding to your observation
no you don't need weirdness like that in
the deployed Bohm Theory what you
measure is what was there just like in
the old Newtonian point of view so you
might say wow it's a return to normalcy
however because I have nonlocality and
also the difficulty in making it a fully
relativistic theory and the difficulty
of making a quantum field theory a
version of it and being a little bit
quick when I don't list all the problems
that the theory has but those challenges
have kept it from gaining momentum in
terms of the level of acceptance that
people have of it as a viable approach
to quantum mechanics anyway I hope I
answered Mohit's question that was my
best interpretation of what it what
Mohit was asking professor green asks my
zombie my zombie lick huh I'm not gonna
parse that name program what new
technology of physics development do you
expect or hope to be released in the
next 10 to 20 years um I don't know I'm
not I'm not a futurist in that sense I
don't really follow the technological
trends but if you asked me where do I
see spectacular rate of progress how can
it not be in AI artificial intelligence
in general artificial intelligence I
mean I had a conversation just before
this whole pandemic thing hit I was in
London I had a conversation with demmas
Hospice you know one of the folks who
really has revolutionized the subject
and it was just amazingly exciting to
hear about the things that they're doing
the possibilities of really for instance
making progress on deep physics problems
by having a system that can learn the
patterns of reality by looking at the
data and probably looking at earlier
attempts to articulate the patterns in
the data mathematically and then perhaps
to be able to go further and suggest
deeper insights that
of today we have not yet our cells made
Wow it's like an artificial physicist
that's exciting you know and and the
whole field of consciousness studies I
think can radically change if we get to
a point of artificially intelligent
beings that seem to really have
qualities that we have long thought to
require a human brain I think these
things are deeply exciting and and we're
I just starting out in science right now
I'd be quite tempted to work in these
areas because it's not that physics has
reached dead end
everything that we're talking about it's
hugely exciting but it's nice to be at
the beginning we're not at the begin one
maybe that's hubris I was gonna say
we're not at the beginning of physics
maybe we are but I would say that you
know we've been at it let me put it this
way there's a corpus there's a
literature in physics that goes way back
I don't know where you want to begin but
let's say there's on the order of three
hundred and fifty years of literature in
physics there isn't that kind of long
literature for artificial intelligence
so it's exciting to be at the early
stages to write the early papers that
really set the agenda for the subject
going forward so that that's my best
answer I think to the question of
exciting development in the next 10 to
20 years
Nevaeh ball as Ken schrödinger's cat
experiment be a proof of parallel
universes
well David Deutsch certainly would say
so David Joyce I think many of you may
know as a deeply insightful physicist
philosopher written some spectacularly
interesting books that I highly
recommend I don't remember all titles
but I think one was called the fabric of
reality I remember that one because my
own book fabric of the cosmos has kind
of a similar title so
people sometimes mix those up I think he
has another book that I've not yet read
I thumbed through that is something like
the start of infinity or the beginning
of infinity
I don't recall but in the fabric of
reality David Deutsch argues that the
kinds of quantum interference processes
the superposition that allows objects to
occupy distinct quantum states
simultaneously he argues that that
really is proof of parallel universes
that the many-worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics is the only way that
picture of the world makes any sense
I was not convinced by his argument I
found it interesting but I don't by any
means think that there's anything that
we currently have in quantum mechanics
that nails down the many-worlds approach
as the only way of thinking about
quantum reality some of my colleagues
don't agree with me Sean Carroll some of
you look at his stuff he's great his a
new book something deeply hidden he
argues and they are forcefully for the
many-worlds approach and these are
arguments that are worth taking
seriously but it would be premature by a
long shot
to say that we have reached consensus
that the many-worlds approach is the
right approach to quantum mechanics
there are many people perhaps they write
less and are less publicly visible who
are very adept at giving reasons why the
many-worlds approach is yet to be
established either mathematically or
observational II so again like multiple
universes not in the quantum sense but
say in the inflation of cosmology sounds
good to have these ideas at your
disposal good to think about them but
it's going to take much more than we
currently have to establish that they
are correct ok but if we got to going
forward here
by the what time is it oh it's a quarter
to five it's sorry
you certainly lose my boys um I see what
we have somebody who have not asked a
question before Joelle Jarvan N
hello from Sweden hello Joelle Joelle in
Sweden I spent a lot of fun time in
Sweden I used to go there pays to go to
Gothenburg I should go to Gothenburg
basically every Christmas and every
summer I would spend two to three months
in Sweden every year when I was younger
I loved the time that I spent there and
once went up to the Lofoten Islands I
know that I gave him the name
pronunciation wrong in Norway that was a
great time but anyway enough of that to
the question thank you for the
inspiration through my theoretical
physics master studies my pleasure I'm
curious do you think that there is an
objective reality similar to a question
we asked other can't did but I don't
because how would you prove it well yeah
so this is a different take on the
earlier question that we addressed and
look it's it's absolutely the case that
we only have access to the purported
objective reality through a subjective
experience right I mean I look around
the world and I imagine that I'm seeing
objective entities that are really there
you know the ceiling my laptop this
display my bottle of water but in
reality you and I both know that this
bottle of water or this yellow right
what is this yellow is this yellow here
no no it's deeply in here right there
are the photons entering my eye tickling
my retina sending a signal into my brain
and my brain because of its evolutionary
development has become adept at
deciphering the signal that my eye is
receiving and saying oh yellow even
projects it out into the world I I don't
I don't see the yellow in my brain I see
the yellow out there even though all
this crackling this cascading of
particles is happening inside my
head so all I have access to is the
crackling of those particles and in fact
I don't even have access to that I can't
see the particles coursing through my
brain I I'm only able to access the
aftermath of those processes how I do
that I don't know neither do you neither
does anybody how is it that I have this
inner experience how is it that I have
this world inside my head that evolution
has led me to believe is out there even
though my experience is just inside so I
agree
you can't ever prove anything about the
objectiveness of those kinds of
subjective experiences however there
comes a point as a physicist where you
put those possibilities you say there's
a real possibility that it's all inside
my head I mean I'm gonna put it to the
side and I'm gonna imagine that there is
an objective world and I'm gonna do all
that I can to try to explain it
mathematically and that's what you do so
it's a very pragmatic perspective my
language in my books and my language
here speaks as though there is this
objective world my attitude is that I am
working on physics to explain that
objective world but you're right in that
I only have subjective capacities to
engage with whatever that objective
world is even if it doesn't exist so so
you're right we find ourselves an
interesting conundrum but from a
flat-footed physics perspective I allow
for that possibility I jump it over here
and then I say it is useful it is useful
for me to imagine that there is an
objective world it's useful free to
imagine that my investigations are
trying to find the patterns in that
objective world and then I simply admit
the fact that my only means of accessing
that objective world is through
subjective experience and I leave it at
that just because there's not much more
I can
do with that observation besides
marveling at it and then going forward
so feel free to answer back on that if
that didn't address it enough I'm happy
to go further if there's anything more
specific that you can guide me toward
yah teach agro wall hello dr. Greene
love the way you explain physics thank
you yeah teach the strings in string
theory are said to be made of pure
energy so what is that energy is it
tangible yes right so
tough question and you know as I've
described earlier even explaining what
energy is in any fundamental sense is a
challenge you go to a physics one
textbook and physics one textbook says
usually energy is the ability to do work
it's the ability to move something
through a distance right it's with
energy that we're able to cause those
processes to take place but that's not
really telling you what energy is is
telling you sort of what energy does you
know if you're asking like I just want
to know what it is you know what is it
made of something you know does it
originate from something more
fundamental I mean these are tough tough
questions but the way that I like to
think about it is this even though I
don't really know what energy is I know
that the universe has it I know that the
universe is able to have particles and
objects move through distances so so the
universe has some energy and then if
string theory is correct I would say
that the strings in string theory are
the most fundamental carriers of the
energy of the universe
again regardless of what that energy is
where it comes from I can't answer
questions like that unfortunately but if
string theory is correct think of the
strings as the most fundamental carriers
of the energy that the universe has and
how do they carry that energy they carry
it through their motion through their
vibration through their intrinsic heft
perhaps and so in this way the strings
in string theory are the most
fundamental currency of the energy
budget that the universe has okay what
else here
hmm
bonnie asks try a Brita water bottle
okay I will try therefore for next time
thank you for that suggestion okay what
else should we talk about here
Nikita asks - Belarus does knowing math
behind physics concepts help you to
imagine the physics concept for example
could you imagine the fourth dimension
knowing its math or would you have
trouble without knowing the math and
without a doubt the answer to that
question is yes so the way I go about
envisioning things in physics that I
understand mathematically I don't
understand everything of course but the
things that I understand mathematically
I use that math to tell me a parallel
story to the visual version that I build
up based upon the mathematical
understanding so for instance when I'm
thinking about the fabric of space
ripping to give one example that I had a
good time participating in the discovery
years ago in order to have a mental
image of the fabric of space tearing I
have the mathematics right here I have
the mathematics of these
three-dimensional spheres shrinking down
small size and I understand what that
means in the equations and then I see
this this field a Higgs like field
changing its expectation value as I go
through the singularity classically
created by the shrunken three sphere and
as it does that the Higgs field blows up
these other two dimensional sphere I can
see all that happening in one part of my
brain because I can run the mathematical
progression in the other part of my
brain I'm not talking left right stuff
here I'm just talking about the kinds of
things that you have in mind and so I'm
constantly using the mathematical
description to inform my visualization
and without that I'd have a lot of
trouble and I've often said that I
wonder how science the good science
writers how they do it maybe they have
enough of the background that they also
have a mathematical understanding but if
you don't have a math understanding I
would have a lot of trouble writing
about any of these are talking about any
of these ideas because if I had
knowledge that was already digested into
a non mathematical form how would I know
if that digested version was leaving out
critical things or if my version of the
digested version was now taking it in a
direction that made it inaccurate or
false so I always need to go back to
first principles the mathematical
understanding have that as my
overarching rubric within which I can
develop visualizations or everyday
language descriptions constantly
checking it against the mass and if I
violate the math I am in a position to
say okay that metaphor that image it
violates the math but that's okay that's
not a vital part of the story I'm
willing to bend the rules there but if I
didn't know the math how would I ever
judge whether a metaphor or an image was
too far away from the actual description
to be worthy of articulating so so the
answer Nikita is absolutely yes and and
to imagine the fourth dimension well
look I can imagine the fourth dimension
again mathematically can I really turn
that into pictures tough I can sort of
turn it into three-dimensional pictures
but so can anybody so I'd say that just
because you have the math doesn't mean
you'll have a visualization but if you
do have the math it will allow your
visualizations to be much more sharply
configured
okay
so
what do we got
what is the idea behind quantum
computers that's a that's a good one and
well there are a lot of ideas behind
quantum computers but I think the
question is what's exactly quantum in a
quantum computer because you have a
computer on your desk right now or in
your pocket your phone's a computer and
it relies upon quantum ideas the
building of those integrated circuits
required quantum mechanics to be able to
move electrons on sufficiently precise
trajectories to carry out the processes
that we want those particular chips to
achieve
so since quantum mechanics is already
part of the story what is a quantum
computer well a quantum computer is one
that doesn't just use quantum mechanics
in the technology per se it actually
uses quantum mechanics in the
calculations an everyday ordinary
computer may have quantum devices within
it but it's carrying out classical
computations we want to carry out
quantum computations because and here's
where the many-worlds approach metaphor
or real I'm not going to commit one way
or another is helpful to think about
things if you're able to do a
calculation in many worlds
simultaneously you could break it up you
could have parts of the computation take
place in different universes and if you
were then able to extract from those
many worlds the answer that you were
looking for
you'd have sped up the computation by
splitting it up among these different
realities now whether or not those many
worlds are real or whether this is just
a way of figuratively talking about the
mathematical process doesn't matter for
the conclusion that you can draw which
is that certain calculations can be done
much more quickly in the quantum realm
because of this divide and conquer if
you will approach and people are getting
to the point where quantum computing is
real and that's that's hugely exciting
and so we'll see where this takes us now
I should say it's not as though any
calculation is a
to this huge speed-up that quantum
computation process promises there are
some calculations that we know how to
break them up the algorithm necessary
for a quantum computer to win by a huge
margin over a classical computer but
there are other processes other
calculations that we don't really have
an algorithm in order to program a
quantum computer to do that calculation
and to be assured that the quantum
version will be lickety-split compared
to the classical version so it's not
that you should think that once quantum
computers are ubiquitous that every
calculation will be sped up exponential
but some will and some important ones
will and who knows as we go forward
people may become better adept at using
the quantum environment to speed up
calculations that today we don't know
how to speed up so all hugely exciting
all definitely very exciting ok
[Music]
so I'm gonna ask Ariana's question
because I know I had one before but what
does it dimension also love that beard
so are you mentioned this that what
beard I'm cleanly shaken I think maybe
it's the lighting or somethin no no or
maybe you talk about my birthmark right
over here on the side of my face which
like when I usually do television I got
makeup on to cover but I'm out here just
a completely natural if you will so
Ariane I'm curious what beard you're
talking about but in any event what is a
dimension is a damn good question and a
dimension is any independent direction a
spacial dimension let me do first is any
independent direction in which motion is
possible so in our world we all know
that motion is possible in three
independent directions I can go this way
back and forth I can go left and right
and I can go up and down of course I can
also go at an angle but you know if you
go to an angle that's just a combination
of moving left and right and then moving
a little bit back and forth and then a
little up and down so an angle is not an
independent direction it's a combination
of this this and that
now when we talk about extra dimensions
of space we really mean that there are
new independent directions in which you
in principle could move that you cannot
access by some combination of left-right
back-forth up-down
that's a curious idea and that's what
string theory demands a handful of extra
directions that in principle if you were
say small enough you'd be able to move
that you simply cannot access through
the known three dimensions of left-right
back-forth and up-down
so I've answered your question Ari and
I'm curious for you to answer my
question but no need if you uh if you
don't want to
so quantum jump says I hope all our
friends from India are well after the
cyclone I was not I've not been
following the news was there big cyclone
I'm sorry to hear that and I as well I
agree hope everyone's ok so whose go
sorry I had to finance it
well life always in other universes
after our University so I guess the
question will there always be life in
other universes after our universe dies
and and look number one we don't know if
there are the universes big part of my
answer to this question but if there are
other universes it depends what kind of
multiverse we're talking about if we're
talking about the many worlds of quantum
mechanics then there's something
interesting happening because if that is
correct and there really are these other
worlds in which the quantum probability
is sort of branch off and other outcomes
of given processes take place then you
can argue pretty convincingly that
there's a nonzero probability that life
can continue indefinitely and if there's
a nonzero probability for that it's not
as though quantum mechanics has within
it a rule that says there's a zero
probability that life will persist
beyond a certain timescale I'm not aware
of any such statement within the laws of
quantum mechanics and that being the
case if every possible outcome takes
place in some universe then however
improbable the nearly or literally
infinite longevity of life might be
there's going to be some realm where
that nearly zero probabilistic outcome
is realized and that would suggest that
life could persist arbitrarily far into
the future in some other universe but
again it's a funny I saw something
somebody mentioned something that I took
solace in that and I don't really it's
just not true at all for instance in my
book until the end of time I spent in
virtually no time on the multiverse I
was focused and I am focused in that
book on how to make sense of the
finite nature of life and the finite
nature of consciousness in this universe
even though the time skills may be large
and seemingly abstract my focus is
trying to make sense of this reality
subjective objective however we want to
describe it so it's fun to talk about
the possibility of life in other
parallel realms but for the serious
questions I was asking in the book until
the end of time I don't think there's a
whole lot of insight that the multiverse
provides Ariane says is my attempt at a
joke okay sorry I didn't get the joke
apologies I must be thick as I don't
know what the joke is but in any event
viewer asks what is the opposite of
entropy and could that have been in
place before the Big Bang
well entropy is not something that I've
yet really spoken about which is kind of
surprising because that's where my head
has been for a while now when you're
talking about the unfolding of the
cosmos over arbitrarily long timescales
the second law of thermodynamics and the
relentless increase in entropy is an
essential guiding principle and yet we
haven't spoken much about it so what is
entropy entropy is a measure in
colloquial terms of the amount of
disorder in a system but that sounds
very subjective what I really mean by
that what I mean by that is take any
physical system and ask yourself how
many ways could have rearranged the
fundamental ingredients and Nan have an
impact on the macroscopic presentation
the look of that system and you know if
you have a very ordered system if you
rearrange its ingredients it becomes
disordered out of order it will
recognizably be different in therefore
there very few rearrangements an entropy
is the count of the number of
rearrangements so if something is very
ordered the count is very small the
entropy is low in a disordered
environment like the air in this room
right now the particles are rearranging
their configuration all the time and yet
as I look around
I don't notice the difference I don't
sense a difference macroscopically has
the same properties and therefore the
air in this room or your room has a
relatively high entropy because there
are a huge number of rearrangements of
the molecules of air that leave your
environment seemingly unchanged
entropy is a count of those
rearrangements entropy therefore is high
for that circumstance now the question
was not not only what is entropy but
what's the opposite of entropy and if
you think about entropy is disorder the
opposite is order and therefore the
question is could that have been in
place before the Big Bang the answer is
yes I don't know about the before part
but at the Big Bang our best description
of the universe imagines that the Big
Bang was highly ordered very low entropy
and we have been living through the
aftermath of that low entropy beginning
ever since entropy has been rising
steadily in some sense since the Big
Bang we are a part way along that
trajectory we are highly ordered beings
existing within an environment headed
toward ever greater disorder the fact
that we're here relies on the low
entropy starting point because if the
universe had a high entropy beginning it
would have been disordered at the
beginning and disordered all the way
through and there'd be no opportunity
for ordered structures like you and me
to form so the answer is yes it's called
the past hypothesis the past hypothesis
as its name indicates hypothesizes does
improve and i pathi sighs is that the
big main the earliest moment of our
observable universe had high order had
low entropy exactly as you viewer as
your name seems to be as I see here have
suggested so absolutely right
so Christopher says hello why do black
holes have different masses and sizes
when all of them consist of an
infinitely dense singularity yeah that's
some a quite natural question and I am
going to I do have some more water under
here so as you watch me pour I'll start
my answer or you probably can't see me
pour out of this source here but you'll
see the aftermath of that and yes you
might say look if a black holes nothing
but this dense thing in the middle if
that thing in the middle has infinite
density then it would seem like all
black holes should be the same they all
have the same infinitely dense core and
number one we don't know what happens at
the core of a black hole let's put that
out there right now you often think
about the core of a black hole as a
position in space where all the stuff
that fell in is sort of compacted
together but that's kind of the wrong
image the center of a black hole is more
like a moment in time as opposed to a
position in space which is one of the
subtlety x' that have to do with black
holes but the idea is the Infinity that
you have in mind that is a misleading
number infinity in that setting really
is one of those singularities which I
said before is the diagnostic that tells
us we don't know what's going on so
don't think about the infinitely dense
core as defining the black hole think
about the stuff that fell into the black
hole as defining it think about the
entire mass of the stuff that fell in as
defining moreover if you have a black
hole already and more stuff falls in
then that increase in mass makes the
event horizon larger so the more stuff
that goes in the bigger the physical
size of the black hole in the sense of
the distance to its event horizon the
larger that size becomes
so the history of the black hole is
vital to understanding why it looks the
way it does and if you have two black
holes where less stuff has fallen into
this one and more stuff is falling into
that one let's say it began the same
lesson here and more and this means this
will grow but not as much as this one
will have grown this won't be much
bigger than that one
so from far away we're sensitive to the
total mass that's fallen into the black
hole that gives a measure of the total
gravitational pull exerted by the black
hole or the total curvature in the
space-time environment created by the
black hole but you need to know the
history because the size to the event
horizon and the gravitational pull that
the black hole exerts on something far
away is determined by the total mass
that falls in even if in both cases the
masses gets crushed down to a very small
size okay
[Music]
uh nazma asks why was bicep 2 proven
wrong
why was bicep 2 proven wrong you maybe
call that bicep 2 was this experiment
down at the South Pole that reported
this very exciting observation of what
they believed was the imprint of ripples
in the fabric of space coming from the
Big Bang itself primordial gravitational
waves leaving an imprint on the cosmic
microwave background radiation that
would be hugely exciting that would be
using observational tools to gain fairly
direct insight into the Big Bang itself
in fact as inflationary cosmology what
we did in episode 30 predicts the
possibility of these primordial
gravitational waves when bicep2 made
that announcement there was great
excitement in the inflationary cosmology
community you may recall there was a
video of Andrei Linde a one of the
founding physicists of inflationary
cosmology someone came to his house with
champagne to inform him of this
observational result and so great
excitement what turned out to be the
case however is that the bicep2 team how
to describe it some would say they
jumped the gun some would say that it's
just part of scientific progression
whatever but the excitement that their
paper initially generated turned out to
be premature because analysis of the
data showed that dust dust in the Milky
Way galaxy can yield the same kind of
signature that they may have mistook for
primordial gravitational waves I say may
have because the writers of that paper
they argue that they never said that the
data proved the existence of primordial
gravitational waves they were just
reporting on their observations some
reading their paper interpreted what
they were saying quite differently so
there's been some argument in the
community about this but it's not worth
read litigating that issue at all if
you're interested again there's a nice
World Science Festival program on that
with some of the you know prime with
some of the founding physicists of
inflation together with the bicep team
and so and so you can take a look at
that but the bottom line answer to the
science question is dust in the Milky
Way galaxy
affected the signal in a way that
mimicked what you would expect from
primordial gravitational waves dust in
the Milky Way not so interesting
primordial gravitational waves hugely
interesting unfortunately it turned out
that the dust explanation is the right
one that's what happens sometimes you
know you think that you've got a big
discovery you're so excited your hearts
in the right place you want to get the
information out there you want people to
know about this
maybe even thinking nobel-prize you know
it's all very human understandable but
it turned out that that data was not
supporting the idea of primordial
gravitational waves so narendra asks
what would happen to entangled particles
if one of them falls into a black hole
with the entanglement still hold and if
yes can there be any interaction
possible between them so narendra you're
asking a question that has puzzled
people over the past few years in a
significant way if you would have asked
that question twenty years ago say the
answer was pretty clear because in
Einstein's theory classical theory of
the general theory of relativity the
edge of a black hole
the event horizon is not a special
location in space there's no signpost
that says black hole event horizon do
not pass if you want to be able to get
out there's nothing like that
the location in space that we would
mathematically recognize as the event
horizon of a black hole is an ordinary
region of space with no distinguishing
characteristics locally so if you fall
over the edge of a black hole you don't
know that you've fallen over an edge
you're just moving through space just as
we're moving through space right now and
because of that the perspective was that
if you have two entangled particles and
one goes over the edge of a black hole
they're still entangled there's nothing
that happens at the horizon that would
cut the entanglement it's after all this
empty space what's changed in recent
years is people thought about this much
more carefully and realized that if the
entanglement persists across the edge of
a black hole it raises certain puzzles
it raises puzzles for the conservation
of information that we believe happens
with the radiation that leaks out of a
black hole
requiring entanglement of a different
sort that winds up being conflict with
the entanglement right across the edge
of a black hole this is led some to
suggest the edge of a black hole might
actually be special quantum mechanically
it may be special classically it's not
but maybe this quantum mechanically and
some have suggested that maybe the edge
of a black hole is a firewall nice image
firewall what does it mean well it would
be a quality of space that basically
snaps entanglement if the thread of
quantum entanglement is broken at the
edge of a black hole energy in some
sense is released that energy would
power a firewall so your questions
potent because if entanglement is
snapped then the edge of a black hole is
very different from what we would have
thought based on Einstein's theory and
people debate this idea of a firewall
there are others who have even more
exotic ideas my friends Sameer Mathur at
Ohio State University has developed over
the course of many years now the fuzz
ball picture of black holes where black
holes are more or less like stars in a
somewhat exotic state of vibrating
strings but there is no event horizon
there is no edge in new way that we
usually think about it in the classical
theory of general relativity so these
are these requests and of course
obviously entanglement would have
different quantities across that because
now there's stuff the fuzzy stuff at the
edge of a black hole so the bottom line
is I'm not sure the answer to your
question nobody is it's debated today
but it's an important one for us to
ultimately resolve
okay
um what do we got here
guy atre asks do I think there's another
possible unified theory other than
string theory of absolutely possible I
am NOT dogmatic about string theory
string theory could easily be irrelevant
and that hopefully is something that
we'll know I'd love to know the answer
to that in my own lifetime having spent
decades working on the theory itself and
only experiment only observation can
tell us that and if string theory is
irrelevant does that mean the
unification program is over now we'll
continue to think about it our
descendants hopefully will continue to
think about it and other ideas will be
put forward other unification schemes
will be pursued so so I again I just I
really want to stress that point I am
interested in the truth I'm not
interested in string theory being that
truth in a sense of it blinding me to
truths that might not be string theory
at ik I just want us to make progress
and if string theory is part of that
great that would be happy I've spent my
life working on this as of my colleagues
around the world how cool that the
things that we're doing are part of the
stepping stone to the deeper
understanding yes I'd love that but
that's not the case that that's cool too
it was not the case we can throw string
theory away
in that way we would have made progress
not by having the right theory but by
discarding the wrong theory and that is
a certain kind of progress - maybe less
exciting but in the end we're part of a
long ongoing journey and we're not going
to answer it in our lifetime so that may
be the best that we can hope for okay
mm-hmm
so I had a question and I touched it and
it went by uh uh what do we got
okay Abbas safar is just try to imagine
what space is even if it seems too hard
for you if you manage that then you will
stop making things up and see reality
like the fish that realizes living in
water and and I I have sympathy with
that comment it is difficult to
recognize the ubiquitous qualities of
the reality you inhabit it's difficult
for the fish to recognize that it's in
water if it's never out of water it has
nothing to compare that experience with
so you begin to become unable to access
qualities of reality that are so central
that they're always with you now when it
comes to space our intuition is moulded
by thinking about things in space I mean
it's very hard for us to think about
taking away space the way we can think
about taking away water for the fish but
the nice thing is there are mathematical
models which do take away space which do
allow us to develop our intuition for at
least the possibility of removing space
so if a fish were able to do that you
know an Einstein fish what would you
call that fish Stein I don't know so if
there's a fish Stein really brilliant
physicist I think that's Lenny
Susskind's combination there so if fish
Stein is this brilliant physicist and
comes up with this theory that allows
you to imagine a reality for the fish
world that doesn't have water it would
open their minds and we kind of done the
same thing in the world with space but
that doesn't mean our theories about
space are the be-all end-all that
they're the the final description but
we've taken your comment to heart and we
do try to imagine a reality and a
mathematical description of that reality
that does not
rely upon a pre-existing environment so
what what fish Stein did for the fish
assists some in our world have done for
us let's see what else
sobani says I think the great professor
is losing it lol I hope I'm not maybe
that was a little too off to defend in
that description let's see what we got
some good questions coming through in
the Indies bike is gravity in another
dimension and I think the answer to that
question is yes well let me qualify it
no let me just I'll be quite general I
think the answer to that is yes our
understanding of gravity as you may have
noted from the episode I did 9 science
general relativity is that gravity's
associated with the geometry of
space-time the warps and curves in
colloquial language and in that sense
once you realize that there's this
intimate association between space-time
itself and gravity gravity is nothing
but the geometry of space-time then you
realize that if space-time has more
dimensions than the ones that we know
about then gravity will be in those
dimensions too so that's the sense in
which gravity is a universal quality of
reality at least reality that is in a
phase that has space and time because
the geometry of that environment the
geometry of the whole environment
including all the dimensions is really
what we mean by gravity and that gives
rise to some interesting implications
because the other forces the
electromagnetic force and nuclear forces
they're not as universal they're not
associated with the warpage of
space-time and therefore you can find
yourself in at least a theoretical
possibility that the electromagnetic and
the nuclear forces might be confined to
certain regions of space-time
whereas gravity extends throughout all
of them and there are theories that have
made use
of that idea you may have heard about
the brain World Series brain as in B ra
and E not be RAIM and those theories
imagine that we live on a membrane a
three-dimensional membrane hard to
picture but using two-dimensional
version it'll be just as good
imagine that we lived on a kind of
two-dimensional membrane floating within
a higher dimensional space-time
environment that means that everything
that we know about would exist on this
membrane so gravity extending through
all the dimensions we would have some of
it because we after all are part of that
space-time expanse
but the electromagnetic force might only
live on our slice the nuclear forces
might only live in our slice and that
disjuncture between where the forces
live in principle can give rise to some
very interesting theories that people
have developed so yes is the short
answer to that question um
five-thirty we're getting on time here
although my wife has not asked me about
dinner and the kids have not yet so I
don't know I guess I'll talk a little
bit more um Krishna
I'm sorry Krishna Krishna evolved is it
possible that you would give a course on
general relativity like you did for
special relativity and um I would love
to and you know of late I think because
people are at home more is my guess I've
had more and more people encouraging me
to do that I'd liked I love doing the
special relativity course and again I've
already mentioned it once before but I
got a mention again so Josh Zimmerman
did all the visuals for that course and
you know there are hundreds hundreds of
animations in the special relativity
course because I wanted it to be deeply
visual I think that's really really
understand things but as you can imagine
it takes a long time to create those
visuals so to do such a course for the
general theory of relativity would
require developing a whole new set of
visuals and it just takes a lot of time
it takes a lot of money right time and
money are intricately interwoven so we'd
have to raise money to do that
we'd have to find the time to do it but
I am thinking that with this with this
lockdown if this happens periodically I
hope it doesn't but if it happens
periodically and I find myself here
we're thinking of setting up a little
studio here that would allow me to make
headway on those kinds of projects when
I'm restrained from working on other
things that would require the world to
be more opened up so so that maybe a
small silver or a tiny silver lining I
don't mean to frame it that way in fact
let me take that back I'm gonna frame it
that way at all that may be one of the
things that I'm able to make headway on
going forward and I'd love to do it so
so keep an eye out again I mentioned
world science-u is relaunching in a week
or two or three I'm not sure what the
answer to that is exactly when but keep
your eyes out for it the special
relativity will be there as will the
master classes and some other additional
content as well but you know you should
sign up look you should sign up to world
science festivals YouTube thing right I
think it's my pointing at the right spot
I don't think it's some place over here
I'm guessing right now because that's
where you can really be kept aware of
everything that we're doing world
science you also has its own YouTube
page we don't use it as much you might
want to sign up to that but yes it's
conceivable that'll do a general
relativity course I'd also like to do a
quantum mechanic course those are the
two other ones that it really really
would love to bring out to the world in
a visual and mathematical way to try to
make these ideas as clear as possible
you know from my from my perspective so
I hope so I hope so but you know life is
short and you have to make decisions on
what to do especially on a kind of
monster project like creating a full
general relativity or quantum mechanics
course okay what else have we got uh
well there's a question that keeps
coming up and a better answer it because
it will keep come so Danny smile
how can a gravitational field escape a
black hole
so I'm going to answer your question
Danny so you can stop asking it I've
seen it like a thousand times written by
and so I would say that a gravitational
doesn't escape a black hole per se
rather what we learned from Einstein is
that the environment around a massive
body responds to the mass energy of that
body and a black hole has mass energy
think about all the stuff that fell in
so that mass energy of the black hole is
influencing the environment of the black
hole and that's what Einstein tells us
it's not that if I have an object
gravity is escaping it it's not the
gravity's escaping the earth in in in
the sense that I think that you have in
mind it's rather that the earth is
impacting its environment in a manner
dictated by the Einstein field equations
so when you write down the Einstein
field equations for the say
Schwarzschild solution that solution
solves the equations of Einstein outside
a spherical body like the earth it
doesn't you can go further and talk
about the interior of the earth but to
understand the gravitational field that
the earth creates in its environment I
mean you never talk about Einstein's
equations inside the earth again not
that you can you can and you can connect
the solutions together and so forth but
if you want to know what's happening
outside the earth Einstein allows you to
solve his equations outside the boundary
of the earth similarly for a black hole
if you want to understand the
gravitational environment that a black
hole creates exterior to itself usov
Einstein's equations in the exterior
realm you don't have to talk about
anything crossing the event horizon of
the black hole okay I hope that gives
some insight in there so rigid and says
by professor I got to go to sleep now
take care and stay safe good night sweet
dreams vision thanks for joining us
josè as if gravity isn't a force yr
gravitons necessary and what you're
mixing in that question are two
descriptions of gravity in the classical
description of gravity of Newton the
gravitational description involves
something called the force of gravity F
equals G m1 m2 over R squared the force
of gravity
Einstein comes along and changes the
description a little bit gravity well
not a little bit a lot of it
gravity is associated to the geometry of
the environment that a body creates so
now it's even a slightly different
language it's warps and curves and
objects traveling along geodesics hey I
never did the geodesic equation but the
third description in terms of gravitons
is a quantum mechanical description
Newton and Einstein are both classical
descriptions in the quantum mechanical
description we do envision that gravity
is communicated from place to place in
much the same way that electromagnetism
is communicated from place to place
electromagnetism photons carry the
electromagnetic force we believe but
we've never detected but we believe a
refined theory suggests that gravity
quantum mechanically is communicated by
gravitons spin to massless particles
whereas a photon is a spin one massless
particle and that's the natural quantum
mechanical language and all of these
languages are useful and you need to
apply whatever language is most relevant
to the kinds of questions that you are
asking if you want to know about the
bending of starlight by the Sun use the
general theory of relativity the curved
trajectory is the one that observations
confirm if you want to launch a rocket
ship to the moon use Newton's
description of the force of gravity good
enough and easier to use to plot the
trajectory to the moon if you want to
understand the gravitational interaction
between two electrons as they scatter
off of each other
then you want to use the quantum
mechanical description of gravity with
gravitons going back and forth between
the electrons that's something that
string theory in principle provides us
and that's controversial because not
everyone believes it's drink there is
the right quantum theory of gravity but
that's the kind of question in which
quantum theory of gravity would be a
useful way of talking about the process
also clearly talking about the big bang
in the center of black holes those are
extreme realms where you need quantum
mechanics and you need gravity if we you
need a quantum mechanical description
okay hmm
few more and then we will I guess wrap
it up let's see t bald
well people differ of a screen I hope
you're doing okay I am I apologize for
frequently asking the same question no
problem I was joking but why is having a
unified theory so important and tabled I
would tell you that there are some
people who do not think it's important
to have a unified theory Freeman Dyson
who I hope you know that name he is one
of the influential physicists from the
middle and late years of the middle you
know 50 60 70 s 80s 19 20th century of
course played a vital role in the
development of quantum electrodynamics
has a lot of creative ideas
the Dyson Sphere you heard about that
you know this way of captious of future
civilization capturing all the energy
coming out from its star Earth only
captures a little part of the sun's
energy but if you had the earth part of
a sphere that would not allow any of the
energy of the Sun to escape into space
that would be a much more efficient way
to go forward anyway so Freeman Dyson
series guy does not think that a unified
theory is really necessary he has
suggested that maybe you used
relativity when gravity is the dominant
influence you know four stars and
galaxies use quantum mechanics when
you're way down at the small scale of
particles electrons neutrinos and things
of that sort and he says maybe the
blending of quantum mechanics and
general relativity into one unified
whole is not only unnecessary it doesn't
exist just wrong for instance he would
even suggest that the notion of a
graviton might be wrong you know
and because that comes from blending
quantum mechanics and general relativity
and and Dyson may have been right in
that perspective I don't agree with that
I think most physicists do not when I
think about the deep interior of a black
hole or the moment of the Big Bang I
know that our equations break down
because they lack the ability to deal
with those extremes of high energy high
mass and small size and it would seem
that a quantum mechanical theory of
gravity would be able to handle those
situations so that's why we're driven to
find this unified theory this quantum
mechanical description of gravity
blending the large and the small because
we really want to understand the moment
of the Big Bang we really want to
understand the singularities which I've
discussed already today inside of a
black hole but does that mean that such
a unified description exists maybe not
maybe there's another way to understand
these extreme realms it doesn't unify
gravity and quantum mechanics as Steven
Weinberg has emphasized on number of
occasions the universe is under no
obligation to please theoretical
physicists we theoretical physicists who
imagine in the guise of Einstein using
the same perspective that he had that
there's got to be a single framework
that blends all of the disparate
disparate explanations of the world
emerging from physics puts them all
together into one unified whole we
believe that that should exist we feel
that it should exist we have an
aesthetic drive to put it all together
into a single unified package but just
because we want it doesn't mean it's
real and maybe one day we will recognize
that this drive toward unity was
misguided that there was another way of
understanding these extreme realms of
the Big Bang and black holes and it had
nothing to do with unification is that
possible yeah definitely possible
are we ready to give up on unification
no not at all
so size says Weinberg is an atheist
brilliant guy much more than Dyson well
I don't want to compare Weinberg and
Dyson Weinberg is an atheist may or is
he an agnostic I don't know who cares
it's a nice observation I'm not sure why
you're telling us but thank you okay
what else
[Music]
I am asks where do quantum and classical
gravity need to be blended and that's
basically what I was mentioning before
you really do need to blend them in
realms that are outside the domain of
Newton's or Einstein's description and
Newton's and Einstein's description are
unable to accurately describe what
happens when the masses are really big
and the sizes are really small so any
situation where the mass gets too big or
the size gets too small is one in which
quantum mechanics and general relativity
need to be brought together and it's
really the conjunction of the two a lot
of mass in a small size a lot of mass
gravity small size quantum if that's
your situation you need them both
gravity and the quantum you need quantum
gravity that's the way to that's at
least one way to think about it okay
an almshouse could there be a fifth
fundamental force absolutely absolutely
in fact there has been chatter of late
about data suggesting another force I
don't know where that stands at the
moment and in the past such chatter has
gone away but even in a theory like
string theory I should say in string
theory there are many more than four
fundamental forces the other forces in
string theory often only emerge at very
very high energies well beyond the reach
of today's accelerators or even any
conceivable accelerator that our species
is going to build but you should know
that fundamentally within the
mathematical structure of certain
approaches to string theory there are
all sorts of other forces they just
aren't relevant at the low energy
environment that we inhabit but they're
there in the equations so an emphatic
yes to the possibility of a fifth force
all right what
5:44 I'd like to break our previous
right have we broken any previous
records what was her what's the longest
we've ever done on this Q&A I don't know
the answer to that
maybe someone maybe someone does but I'm
gonna go a little bit longer as long as
there's no tornadoes today nice day out
here and you know when I when I finished
this session I've got to immediately
start cooking I don't I'm not in the
mood to start cooking right now so I'm
procrastinating on making tonight's
dinner all right you're not all that
interested in that nonsense so let me
get back to physics Reverend Jonathan
Barlow
he asks Brian can tachyons
faster-than-light particles actually be
the force carrying particles of gravity
the answer to that is no the force
carrying particle for gravity really
means to be a massless spin-2 particle
if you look at tachyons they're
particles that actually have imaginary
mass traveling faster than the speed of
light and they yield all sorts of issues
of consistency that you know you can
stand on your head and maybe make them
work but most physicists do not take
tachyons too seriously but most
physicists do take the force of gravity
mm-hmm and gravitons quite seriously all
right um let's see
multiplier fan is saying how are you and
if that's to me or to the group I'm
doing well I'm having a little bit of
sore throat issues as you can tell but
let's see I am says break some records
all right I think we're on the verge of
that Alexandra Kara Raymond ask is it
tofu again I eat a lot of tofu yeah I'm
pretty sure it's tofu tonight we are
solo and are in our food stocks right
now that tofu I think it's the only
thing that is left what will it be it
will be
tofu and homemade black bean sauce a
little bit of rice probably maybe a
little bit of cold sesame noodles with
it too and my son loves those so the
record was 2 hours in 44 minutes we have
now smashed that I think with 2 hours
and 46 minutes but Farah asks what do
you think of the serious genius and I've
only I only saw the first episode we're
not episode I guess by genius you mean
that series I think that had Einstein
like the 10 part series I only saw the
first episode of that first incarnation
of genius and I thought it was as a film
really well done it was captivating it
focused more obviously an Einstein the
man you know the opening scene Wow Jesus
Einstein the man as opposed to Einstein
the scientist and I think people find
that quite interesting I found it a nice
contrast to the approach that we took in
our PBS special the one that I've
mentioned from time to time you know
like Falls the live stage work that we
had it was broadcast nationally in the
United States I don't think it's been
broadcast anywhere else in the world we
have to work on that I'd like it to be
broadcast elsewhere but that focus much
more on Einstein the scientist and
that's the story look I think all the
stories are interesting but the one that
really captures me obviously as a
physicist is how radically changed the
world one one guy in the span of a
single lifetime change so much of our
thinking and to me that's the
inspirational story and yeah I'd love to
know more about Einstein the person and
that's good but for my taste it's really
Einstein the scientist that really gets
me gets me fired up so junus yo you nice
ask did Einstein's wife wife helped him
with the math that was that was
something that was said by people during
a period of time that Mileva Maric I'm
not sure how to pronounce her last name
so it correct me on that that's how it's
spelled that maleva helplines dying with
the mathematics now I believe it was
she was good apparently she was a fine
physicist did well in school there's no
evidence that she had the genius
capacity of Einstein and I'm pretty sure
that subsequent research has debunked
the idea that she was really the force
behind Einsteins discovery in special
relativity there's really no evidence as
far as I know for that story
obviously it's a would be an interesting
story it would be a romantic story it'd
be like that film was it called the wife
was that the film in which the wife of
the the writer who won the Nobel
laureate Nobel Prize in Literature she
actually wrote all the books it was it
called the wife Helena may have been or
maybe I'm talking about the wrong film
somebody tell me if I've got that right
but that would be the story of course in
this case maybe that rumor of malaya was
the inspiration for that film I don't
know but there's no evidence as far as I
know that malade was behind the mask
that allowed Einstein to come forward
with special theory of relativity
marriage someone to expect 11 marriage
thank you I don't know okay thank you I
trust you more than I trust me diem are
there any theories about what the
singularity that may have existed before
the Big Bang was and there are many
theories we've discussed some of them
here on various occasions there are
bouncing cosmologies where we are living
in the aftermath of one cycle in what
might be an infinitely long progression
of cycle after cycle expansion
contraction bounce expansion contraction
so the Big Bang singularity may have
just been a moment between the previous
period of contraction and the subsequent
period of expansion that's one
possibility there are other theories
even in string theory there's an idea
that people worked on one of the
founders of string theory Gabriele
Veneziano worked on a pre Big Bang
scenario for a number of years in which
the universe would have in some sense
begun big in the infinite past and then
it in some sense the right frame of
reference it would have collapsed down
and then not bouncing in the sense of
going over and over again but it would
have had a prehistory our development
would have had a prehistory in the far
past so so people do write down theories
they develop these ideas they try to
analyze the singularity try to make
sense of the Big Bang and some theories
claim that they have there's no
consensus though that any of these
description are the right one Pryor goes
to the freewill question I'm gonna put
that off prior if you don't mind I've
answered it before it's in chapter 5 of
my book again I'm not asking you to buy
it
get a bootleg copy read it that really
captures with precision my perspective
on freewill and again as I mentioned
before anybody wants to take my class I
wish I could offer it for free maybe
there's a way to audit it for free
some are taking it for credit it starts
next Tuesday Tuesdays and Thursdays from
6 p.m. to 9 p.m. and maybe too late for
some of you guys who are in other
countries but I'll be talking about that
in detail there as well and again it's
not that I don't want to talk about here
it's just that it's it's 8 to 6 it's
almost 6 o'clock and I think it'll take
us too far down that rabbit hole that's
the only this is a good question to end
on it just went by where'd it go I don't
know there's some question about an
ultimate truth I liked it but now it
went by too fast see if I can find it
again trying to find it I can't seem to
find it whatever I guess I'll move on
looking for the
question this isn't the final one do I
know Robert Lawrence kun kun I do
he I've been at conferences with him
he's a good guy I'm really curious about
deep questions I like him on what his
m-theory sort of already did the hem
theory so string theory on steroids
string theory done with a greater degree
of mathematical precision that's really
what it is sir Brian just a bunked the
board good for Lincoln theorem no no no
no no that's not the board Guth of
Lincoln theorem tells us that if you if
you're gonna follow any trajectory far
back you're going to encounter a
singularity but but it's not that every
trajectory it's that singularity on the
same singular surface so you can have
trajectories that go farther and farther
back and again that's only in the
context of the assumptions made in that
theorem so no that is not my point let's
see oh here's one so Sameer cut cut cut
cut cut car sorry is there one single
ultimate truth what is your opinion I
think I'll be my final question for
today cuz nice and philosophical and um
I don't think there's a single ultimate
truth I think there are many truths I
think the notion that truth is a
singular essence or quality has led to
much strife in the world much dissension
much unnecessary bloodshed I think that
there are qualities of the world that
are objectively accessible and what I
mean by that is not that we can get
outside of our heads we already
discussed that earlier everything that
we know about the world is subjective in
here but what I'm saying is their
qualities of the world that if we
attempt to access them we will access
the same thing like as I said before the
mass of the electron the electromagnetic
charge on the electron and so
but those truths are only one kind of
truth in the world and the patterns that
we develop to explain those qualities of
the world via the standard model of
particle physics be general relativity
be at whatever those are accessing one
kind of truth which is that objective
third-party accessible qualities and
patterns of the world the inner kinds of
truth the subjective kinds of truth that
we as individuals have access to through
whatever meditation through
introspection through self-awareness
through inner experience through the
experience of music or art or theater or
reading literature or poetry those
truths are equally real they're not
truths that are third-party accessible
they're not truths that are available to
everybody in the same way because they
are deeply dependent on the specific
icon equalities of our own particle
arrangement the way our brains are
configured the experiences that we've
had the genetic makeup that we acquired
from our parents so those truths are
real those truths are valuable those
truths are a vital part of a complete
understanding of what it means to be a
human being living in this universe and
those truths are different for each of
us and so in that sense the totality of
truths needs to be forefront in people's
minds so it's not that your God is
better than my god it's not that your
theory about consciousness is better
than my theory it's not that your art is
better than my art it's the recognition
that we are all on a journey to better
understand ourselves to better
understand the world and we get that
better understanding through a variety
of sources physics is one source it
answers the kinds of questions that we
have been primarily focusing upon here
today but if somebody else was in this
chair and they were talking about the
truths that emerge at higher levels of
understanding the truths say of biology
chemistry the truths of psychology or
philosophy the truths of art the truths
of anything else that we use as a tool
of investigation into the nature of
reality
those are vital truths those are not
truths that physics directly provides to
us and the truths that also come from
religious exploration from conscious
introspection vital part of the story -
and those are the stories that we as
individuals tell those are not stories
that we have objective descriptions that
we can all agree on because they're
accessing qualities of the world that we
all are able to touch in one way or
another so an answer to your question I
do not think there's one single truth
you have to recognize that there are
many truths many valuable truths and the
beauty of life is that we are equipped
to experience those truth to pursue
those truths and in all their wonderful
very expect from a possibilities that
doesn't mean that their qualities of the
world that aren't amenable to factual
discussion are their qualities out there
that absolutely science can give us
insight into like climate or viruses or
things of that sort
yes not open to opinion or discussion at
this stage of understanding but are
there other truths that are much more
fluid and flexible and much more
sensitive to the individual yeah and
they're equally important all right with
that I think I'm just about done we're
at 5:59 so I don't know it's close to
three hours of conversation maybe I hope
you've enjoyed the time that we've had
together again as I mentioned at the
outset your daily equation will be a
little bit less frequent I'm going to
still try to create some episodes so
look out for those and I'll try to do
this next week these sessions are fun
again I may be doing a reddit our Reddit
public access network discussion next
Friday at 2:00 so if you want to join us
at 2 o'clock for that and then we can
segue into this one at 3 o'clock that
will be a possibility to again follow me
on Twitter if you sort of want to keep
up to date on the things that I'm doing
I have no means of connecting with you
except during these sessions it'd be
really useful if I had a confidence that
if I wrote down something on Twitter
like I'm not going to do a daily
equation today or I'm not gonna do a
live session that thought I would reach
you so follow me on Twitter it's at be
green follow me on Facebook if you'd
like a lot of stuff I post there
I think it's be green I don't know what
I am on Facebook sorry but easy to find
and and also subscribe to the world
science festival I think this is their
right hand it's always confusing I think
this is pointing at this subscribe
button I hope it's there on the screen
so sign up and and we will connect again
sometime during this week hopefully with
new episodes of your daily equation if I
can get to it I will try against my
first week of teaching I may not but
certainly by next Friday we can join up
here again alright thanks for your
questions
enjoyed it see you guys later